Germany has announced lockdowns for
people who are unvaccinated very similar
to what we saw in Australia and it was
funny I'm sorry not Australia Austria
Australia is way worse actually they're
putting people in camps but we'll get to
that in Austria they announced this then
a couple weeks later they're like you
know what we're locking everybody down
even if you are vaccinated Germany is
also planning mandatory vaccinations by
government Force so this is what we can
expect I think in the U.S we'll probably
see lockdowns Joe Biden says he doesn't
want them
for now
if people get vaccinated so we'll see
how that plays out but we also have this
interesting story we talked about it a
little bit the other day this
billionaire says he believes is a 30
chance in the next 10 years we'll have a
civil war like conflict in the U.S now
maybe he's wrong I don't know is that
the first person to say it and maybe all
we're really getting is a bunch of
different people repeating each other
and believing each other but I think
based on what we've seen with red States
blue States now Roe v Wade people
believe will be overturned come June
blue states are going to lose their mind
there's already antifa violence and now
we have a study from Harvard that says
Millennials actually fear Civil War so
that'll be interesting we'll talk about
that and we've got to talk about
Democrats man a red wave is coming 19
Democrats have abandoned their seats
well more than what the Republicans
actually need to take the house so it
should be fascinating and and we got
really big news
Rumble has effectively sold to an
Institutional investment firm via a SPAC
a special uh what a specimen for a
special um no I'm sorry to pull this up
um I don't forgot what it's called it's
an acquisition company
um I did I just I'm I'm just uh
forgetting the word but anyway the idea
is they've teamed up with this
institutional investment firm to go
public through a shell company and a lot
of people are saying wow there it is
your free speech will only go so far as
the public investment is willing to
tolerate so the end of the Free Speech
Free Speech there SPAC special purpose
acquisition company it's created just to
make the acquisition and then it becomes
part of Rumble once the acquisition is
well no Rumble becomes that company
right yeah so it's basically a long
story short in institutional investors
are now the advisors to rumble and have
a huge role and are merging with them
and that also means that locals
which is a part of that which was which
sold to rumble is now all involved in
that and I think this is possibly a good
thing but um I think short-term good
long-term apocalyptic bad it exploited
people in a lot of ways and I'm not
happy about it but we'll get into all
that stuff uh we got some great people
hanging out with us we got uh John
miltimore from fee
the foundation for economic education
happy to be here Tim right on man is
what do you do what do you what do you
do I'm the managing editor that fee uh
we're like we we you know evangelize on
free markets economics uh we're a
Libertarian group been around since I
think 1946. wow amazing cool well we got
uh we got a lot to talk about we'll talk
about the acquisition and free speech
and all that stuff that'll be fun
hey Tim yeah I just wanted to remind
everyone that I like to really help
people and uh that's what I do what I do
and that's why I also made this very
handy chart to let people recognize
their local parasites so if you're
looking to help identify deer ticks dog
ticks and lunatics like this picture of
Dr fauci you can also help spread
awareness by purchasing this t-shirt and
wearing it to the general public in a
way where it still can't be censored for
now and the best way for you to do that
and to keep me here is of course go to
thebestpoliticalshorts.com and because
you do I'm still here thank you so much
for having me is there a limit on how
many I can buy uh no there's not buy
them all give me your friends and family
uh Hey guys everyone happy to be here as
well Ian Crossland what's up I am also
here in the corner pushing buttons as I
usually am very excited to be here as
well ladies and gentlemen before we get
started we got an awesome sponsor it is
backupsolarbank.com and we shouted them
out on Monday and I guess we had a great
response people were really into it it's
very simple it is a solar powered
battery backup USB charging three
different USB ports to charge you can
charge out of it's got an LED light on
it uses a flashlight and it's got
wireless charging on the back it really
is that simple go to backupsolarbank.com
they're doing 47 off and if you use the
promo code cyber monday yes I know it is
Thursday but uh we did this a couple
days ago and people were really into it
they liked it so much that we got asked
hey would you want to shout it out again
I said absolutely I love this stuff it's
a 20 000 milliamp battery that that's
basically like 10 cell phone charges so
if you need a backup battery which I
think everybody does I certainly have
one and you want one that's got a
flashlight wireless charging and you
want to support the show go to
backupsolarbank.com 47 off and an
additional 25 off if you use the promo
code Cyber Monday but don't forget to go
to timcast.com and become a member to
get access to our exclusive members only
segments from the timcast IRL podcast
we'll have one up around 11 or so p.m
tonight and we just I believe we just
had a another reporter to do more work
we actually just flew out another
journalist who's uh going on the ground
to cover some of these protests we got
that stuff up and uh we got some great
merch so become a member at timcast.com
support us but now I give you what I'm
very proud of you're gonna love this
we have a new t-shirt and we actually
pinned the link to the poster version of
this this is our visit Howard Springs
t-shirt why you you ask what is Howard
Springs Tim well this is the totally
voluntary relocation camp in Australia
and you can see these very lovely people
sitting on the beach
surrounded by razor wire as a police
boat chases a man trying to escape but
visit Howard Springs totally voluntary
relocation Camp Australia and on the
back it says visit today and enjoy your
stay and we also have a poster version
if you go to timcast.com click store or
for the poster version it's in the the
chat for the live show you can click on
that we I I'm I'm loving it um you know
I've been feuding with the propagandists
trying to claim that the police actually
aren't arresting teenagers escaping the
quarantine facility which is insane
because it's like reported by the
guardian but they're really trying to
claim this stuff isn't happening well
I'll tell you what you want to come at
me here's what I'll do I'll make merch
about it and then we'll have propaganda
posters ourselves mocking the claims
they're making and it'll help fund all
our work so if you like the idea make
sure you pick that up let's get into
this first story we got it from CNN I
love using CNN as a source when we have
horrifying stories because now it has to
be true right Germany lost down
unvaccinated people as Leaders plan to
make shots compulsory CNN says
unvaccinated people will be banned from
accessing all but the most essential
businesses such as supermarkets and
pharmacies to curb the spread of the
chronovirus outgoing Chancellor Angela
Merkel and our successor Olaf Schultz
announced Thursday following crisis
talks with regional leaders those who
have recently recovered from covid-19
are not covered by the ban the pair also
backed proposals for mandatory
vaccinations which if voted through the
parliament could take effect from
February at the earliest
okay this is happening it has been two
years
and they're still saying don't worry if
we do this it'll stop the spread of
coven
it's people have said covet is endemic
it's a part of our Lives now it'll be
seasonal like the flu let me just add to
that the authoritarianism is now endemic
as well countries will keep implementing
completely BS policies they'll keep
expanding the mandates and my
understanding and I believe this might
be in here what I was reading is that
they said vaccines will be mandatory and
they will expire every nine months let
me see if I can uh find that
um in here it was in a different here we
go here we go she had that vaccinated
people will lose their vaccination
status nine months after getting their
last shot apparently in an effort to
incur encourage booster uptake what that
means is
there is no limit to the amount of shots
you have to get they are saying once
every nine months you must get a shot
Welcome to the New World Order excuse me
the new normal and uh what was
Einstein's definition of insanity
because it seems like we're living it
every single day this is just crazy
there's these video footages there's
these photos coming out of people being
segregated in a supermarket from being
vaxxed and unvaxed there's police
officers walking around rudely
interrupting people's private dinners
rudely interrupting people's haircuts
being like give me your gosh Dawn
paperwork right now I've been making my
own German translations of them on my
own YouTube channel but that's a
separate topic but it's absolutely
ridiculous to have a concept and idea
where the state needs to have you have
your paperwork everywhere you go not
just your identification your medical
records and to have permission from the
state to live your life like a normal
person who gave them this power I didn't
John something tells me that you're
interested in Freedom you know you the
foundation for economic education right
is that it yeah no we are uh and if you
look like like here's the thing I would
oppose these even if they worked um but
they don't work anybody who's clinging
to the idea that the vaccines are
stopping or even reducing transmission I
don't think they're looking at the data
clearly if you look anybody know the
highest vaccinated state in the U.S
uh Vermont Vermont and if you look at if
you look at Vermont's cases right now
they have more cases right now than they
did last year
um they I try to be careful with
correlation though well sure but I mean
you you can't look at that anybody that
looks at the numbers and and says we
have vaccination rate 85 percent but our
cases are through the roof like it's not
stopping the data I hear you one more
data point we need though are they
breakthrough cases well how do you mean
Define breakthrough are the people who
are getting coveted vaccinated yes they
have to that's that's well it's not
necessarily so there could be you know
the vaccination rate the Breakthrough
rate is much much exponentially higher
than we were told at the beginning you
know I wrote an article about this back
in August before anybody before people
were really talking about the
Breakthrough rate
um at the time you you the media was
reporting something point three percent
maybe a half percent you know maybe at
one percent well we know it's much much
higher than that
um we have gobs of data that supports
that as people you know well so so I
think there's actually a simple if we
step back yeah when Germany says you
have to get vaccinated every nine months
I think what the issue is it may be the
most vaccinated State the vaccines May
reduce transmission but they wear off
after a certain amount of time you're
still legally vaccinated but the
efficacy has dropped to the point where
you may as well not be yeah according to
the Associated Press Germany's
vaccinated population is 68.7 percent
which is the majority of its population
they have seen a surge in cases and I
think they're going to do what Austria
did Austria also highly vaccinated
country uh experiencing a lot of new
cases and originally they locked down
only the unvaccinated and then a couple
days later they locked everyone down
because they were using it as an
emotional Ploy they knew what they were
doing in my opinion from my perspective
and they were just using this larger
kind of extortion effort in order to try
to get people to take this procedure
whether you want to take this procedure
or not that's your decision we're not
giving you any medical advice we're not
telling you what to do here's the
important thing I think uh it was
obvious from the get-go and they were
like in New York just get one shot and
then everything will go back to normal
and then they're like okay well now it's
two and now you've got The Daily Beast
coming up being like we screwed up it's
not a booster three shots is the vaccine
I think it's fairly obvious that you
give them an inch they're going to keep
pushing on it I also think when it comes
to the vaccine
I think it probably does what they say
it does they're literally telling us it
stops working like the efficacy declines
so I don't think we need to look too
deep I mean that's just my opinion
ultimately it comes down to you know
don't come to me for medical advice I
just want to be clear I'm not a anti-vex
I encouraged several family members take
the vaccine you're in a risk group where
I think it makes sense but you're going
to need a booster my wife took the back
seat and I said I think it makes sense
um and and I had covid in March it was a
very very unpleasant experience I was
probably the sickest I've been for for
that length of time
um so covid's real it's it's it's it's
deadly all these problems I'm just I'm
just but I I want to be clear I think
the idea that the vaccine everybody
admits it doesn't stop transmission we
have very good data that it doesn't
reduce it now like there's other data
that conflicts it with that but but we
we published uh coverage of a report the
the European Journal of epidemiology I
believe it was they they looked at 67
countries
um in in thousands of of counties
um across the world and they said
there's very little correlation there
and to the extent that there is a
vaccinated areas had slightly higher
cases now this is transmission the
vaccines work at reducing your risk of
being hospitalized or dying I think I
think we have tons of evidence to
support that of covid if you take this
your chances of dying of or being
hospitalized with covid they fall you
know dramatically but the idea that they
they stop transmission is is is not true
and they did it they reduced it I think
you know I think there's there's we have
sound data that says maybe they don't
reduce transmission it's tough I will
say funny funny enough one of YouTube's
rules is that if you claim the vaccine
is is a guaranteed way to prevent covet
it's actually bannable and they say if
it's if you claim it's a guaranteed way
to stop transmission it's bannable yeah
I do think I do think so that the the
vaccine we're dealing with mRNA vaccines
not like the was it attenuated virus is
that what it's called the other ones we
we do have it's novovax the an
attenuated one like they're they're
doing a new I don't know that I don't
know they're doing like another one
that's like more of a traditional kind
of vaccine because they needed like the
genome or something
I think I think it's fairly
straightforward I think it's a political
issue I think the vaccine probably does
what they say it does and when they come
out and say you know what you actually
need a booster uh you probably need
another a fourth shot I'm like okay
that's not tenable yeah policy wise I'm
like by all means come out and and give
me your advice you know and and Report
what the reports are saying and I think
yeah okay maybe it makes sense that in
the first four to six months it'll
reduce transmission or reduce severity
but what happens is you end up with
people who all got vaccinated in March
it's December and now we're like look
the cases are through the roof I'm like
yo they got vaccinated eight months ago
and people aren't getting their booster
shots it is not feasible economically
and politically to mandate nine boosters
at every nine months people aren't going
to do it Bill Maher said he's not going
to do it and so the way I look at it is
it's not so much the vaccines I think
it's the vaccine mandates are just
completely nonsensical yeah I I would
disagree with you a little bit because I
don't think we know yet the data's still
not in and I think we should say that we
don't know but there you know know
correlation does not prove causation and
that's an important distinction here but
when we look at the omnicron variant the
first case was detected in San Francisco
from a fully vaccinated person the
second case was detected in Minnesota
from a triple vaxed person who just had
his booster shot in November the third
case was also from a double vax person
in Colorado and it got caught you know
correlation does not prove causation but
when we look at the United Kingdom
Singapore Ireland Israel Gibraltar a lot
of places that had some of the highest
vaccine rates are dealing with some of
the highest case numbers again we don't
know what that means that's just the
data there's a number of circumstances
involved here but that data should be at
least debated and talked about I think
it's important too like we are talking
cases right now
um we've been focusing on cases for a
long time I think you know if we look
even whether or cases are rampant covet
deaths are not you know like the
vaccines are having some success there
um you know but the Omicron
everything I've read so far says it
might be more mild and so like are we
concerned that we that the cases are you
know it might be very transmissible like
all those are problems
um but again when we see Nations going
into full-blown knockdowns and things
it's another overreaction
um and when you're talking about using
State Force to compel people to you know
get vaccinated or you can't go to a
store or go out in public
um like it's very dangerous and we need
to you know I get it talking about this
stuff is uncomfortable talking about
vaccines you're always worried you know
like even a mixed company right you it's
always you're kind of you know
[ __ ] footing around a little bit trying
to you don't want to offend people but
we need to be honest like like using
using the state to force people in this
way is is very very frightening very
dangerous that's that's that's the issue
for me as I say you know I'm not a
scientist I'm a doctor and it's the
issue I have with it is it's so easy to
be wrong and you end up in a place where
you're like I read this report that says
this and then what do you do when you're
actually sitting in front of someone who
is a doctor who is a scientist and
they're like dude you have no idea what
you're talking about I'm like you know
what I got to be honest you're right but
you know what I do know what I'm talking
about when I'm talking about Freedom I'm
a freedom expert policy wise this will
not work centralization command
economies all this stupid BS mandated
medical procedures it doesn't work let's
talk about what's going on in Australia
again because I love to they have
created camps they have just uh we did
the story the other day they arrested
three teenagers who tested negative
because they tried escaping from the
camp how is this making anything better
I don't think it is it's making it worse
and I think this is what they want they
want to to use a crisis to gain more
control
and it's working because I'll throw it
back to when you ask the question about
all these areas that have high
vaccination rates but also High case
rate
population density correlates with
politics and likelihood of infection so
New York for instance overwhelmingly
blue overwhelm a higher vaccination rate
also a whole bunch of people jam-packed
together in one of the densest
populations in the world and so the
likelihood they're going to spread stuff
and have you know more contact with
different strains or whatever virus yeah
it's really really high so there's a
correlation there that's why I'm like we
got to be careful about playing
correlation games because yeah but but
even that Tim even that Tim has
contested when you look at Vermont and
Florida Florida has a huge elderly
population huge uh major metropolitan
areas and and it's a far more
significant state that was more at risk
than New York but if you look at the
case numbers per capita Florida right
now has the lowest case numbers and they
have no mask mandates no uh vaccine
mandates no restrictions no lockdowns
compared to new and they also have
completely different weather and they
are and different treatments and they
also have different treatments and they
also probably have heard immunity yes so
I certainly think the policy is the
issue this this is the the struggle I
have with trying to argue Math and
Science I'm like we don't need to
Florida's policy clearly works you give
people freedom and sure enough whoa look
at that they provided monoclonal
antibodies to people free of charge you
show up to a clinic boom you're all
better I got it it worked for me it's an
emergency use authorization uh treatment
then you look up a lot of these other
states some of them don't offer this and
they lock you down and we saw this very
early on when it came to the spread of
this what do you need you need Vitamin D
you need Vitamin C you need zinc you
need iron you and all this stuff people
staying in their homes are are more
likely to circulate air this is one of
the studies that came out
um a while like last year like mid-2020
they said that people who are in the
house were more likely to transmit this
because they were more likely to be in
close contact with people and have
Cycles recycled air no I remember that
study like if you remember like early in
the pandemic Andrew Cuomo you know had
one of his press conferences and he was
you know just just talking to the media
he said what really surprised us is it's
not Frontline workers getting sick it's
not homeless people he said it's people
are getting sick in their homes and and
wow sure enough months later you know we
we had some good hard data that shows
people the majority of people are
infected in their own home I want to
know how many people sat in their house
by themselves in between 20 January 1st
2020 and now sat in their house by
themselves with a mask on
how many people I'd be terrified to find
out put a one in the things if you
actually did that type one in the car no
they're gonna say no it's gonna hate on
you it's it's an anonymous just nobody
and you're right yeah I have seen people
driving in their cars with masks on and
they're by themselves hey I did that
once and I will say I'm that guy because
I had coven and I'm like well I don't
wanna I'm driving to the doctor now it's
been I had it for a week and and I'm
like well I don't what if I cough on the
in the car or something I'm like so I
had it I'm that guy driving in my car
with a mascot I was like um we I
contract a covet about a month ago and
it was pretty brutal like you were
saying I I went through after I got out
of my system I had this like feeling
like well I got a mask so okay I'm a
little bit more protective like I felt
that but then like 10 hours later the
mask was all wet from my breath and it
was disgusting peeling it off my face
and it the thought of it protecting me
had completely gone out the window at
that point because it was dirty you know
I just realized everyone's spamming one
in the chat yeah they're all lying you
guys didn't wear your masks in your
house don't troll on me I'm just like
you know what I don't believe this smash
the like button yeah
there you go if you wore it or not smash
that let's let's let's before we go one
last point I I want to make because
there's something you said Tim
um and I I saw it on on Twitter recently
Gavin Newsom came out and he said it
pains me to say this but this thing is
seasonal I don't know if you guys saw
that but but Newsome he came out and
said it and and I'm like well you know a
lot of smart people I know like I I
wasn't quite willing to go there yet
myself but I was looking at charts and
you put them and you can see in
different states in different areas it
looks like this is moving seasonally
um and and Newsome came out and said it
and and so I think we need to accept the
fact all our policies all everything
we're trying to do to contain the virus
you know nature is nature it's moving
yeah five times that's a good point a
good point about Florida
um people right now are indoors for the
winter in a lot of places in Florida
they're outside yeah where it's cold and
if you go away so next year Florida if
you look at Florida in July August next
year you know what their numbers are
going to be high again because everyone
goes back inside for the air
conditioning all right that's my
prediction right I wonder how many
people that are getting vaccinated are
getting vaccinated for different
variants I don't think any of you guys
can answer this question and I would
love it I don't think there's a vaccine
for different variants I think it's just
one vaccine well the White House
official stance on this new variant is
you need to get vaccinated you need to
get boosted in order to deal with the
omnicron variant which the first
preliminary cases are affecting
vaccinated people Dr fauci just came out
today and said that you're gonna have to
get a vaccine once a year uh and their
official stance and the Biden
administration's first move against
omnicron is to get children vaccinated
uh as young as five we got it we gotta
jump to the story about the Republican
party we got this from Breitbart
exclusive tool to enforce orwellian
rules 80 House Republicans helped pass a
bill to fund Federal vaccination
database according to the bill also
called HR 550 the government would
provide 400 million in taxpayer dollars
to fund immunization system data data
modernization and expansion a system
otherwise defined as a confidential
population-based computerized database
that records immunization doses
administered by any health care provided
to persons within the geographic area
covered by that database I want to point
out it's called the immunization
infrastructure the covet vaccine does
not immunize you okay this is very very
important distinction you will not be
immune okay the YouTube rules are very
clear on this one okay the covet vaccine
reduces the likelihood you'll get it
reduces the severity and uh and if you
do get it you know hospitalization all
that is reduced as well there have been
some graphs about it but that's
important because they're calling it The
immunization infrastructure
modernization act and I think it's
important the New York daily news
reported on LeBron James getting coveted
and it said not even the king is immune
to covid and I'm like and he's fully
vaxxed yep I think this is the narrative
here that the vaccine is not
immunization it is vaccination and now I
guess the definition has changed to mean
it reduces your likelihood of catching
and having a severe case
so uh just one final thought is to move
into this
we had 80 Republicans sign on board with
this I don't believe that a red wave is
going to save Americans Freedom yeah
absolutely not I mean we've been talking
about this for a while be prepared to be
disappointed by the people who are going
to be The Fall Guys it's it's just like
wrestling they're going to come in
they're going to be you know they're
pretending to be the bad guys now
they're going to be the popular guys but
it's all a show it's all scripted in so
many different ways Dan Crenshaw I heard
also voted for this and to see 80 House
Republicans vote for federal vaccine
registry what do you think registration
will lead to I mean it's common sense
it's what's happening in Germany it's
what's happening in Australia it's
what's happening in Israel it's what's
happening in the United Kingdom they
need a database of everyone complying
because now they know who's playing ball
and who's not it's no longer going to be
the paper that's your vaccine proof it's
going to be a federal digital track
trace and database system which again
will be integrated into the social
credit score which we've been warning
about from the very beginning of this
but it said it was confidential they're
saying yeah do you think a Government
Federal Register
how can anything go wrong
consolidating data like that
confidential means they get to read
through your private and so do their
friends this is at the same time as the
federal government uh bidens
um kovitz are literally was on the
national media today saying that
everything's on the table to implement a
domestic vaccine passport when it comes
to Interstate travel so this is
literally what the there's politicians
there's ruling Elites in the United
States that are seething that are
waiting to implement what Australia and
what Germany have already implemented
they are waiting to implement this and
it's terrifying the CDC just gave
themselves new surveillance powers in
order to track this new variant who who
allowed them to to have surveillance
Powers they did themselves they're
acting more and more like just a totally
run away undemocratic unfree government
that thinks they could impose their will
onto anyone when they want and that's
absolutely crazy and dangerous so the
founding fathers right they're probably
like sitting around Ben Franklin's
living room they smoked a lot so they're
probably stoned or probably on opium or
something and then Jefferson's like dude
what if like we make a government
and it goes nuts and then Ben was like
whoa
and then Tom's like yo we should give
everyone the right to keep and bear arms
and then it was like Ben was like dude
dude we don't give it man God gives it
it's like yo you're right God gives all
this that might be the best description
I've ever heard
they're probably drinking you know it's
probably at a pub and there's no doubt
and they were alive have you ever looked
back and see what they they drove what
they drank in some of these Continental
Congress meetings
insane amounts of alcohol I I wrote
something on it once years ago I'm like
because you will not believe how much
alcohol they consumed I didn't believe
it well they needed to because a lot of
the water wasn't safe for them to drink
so a lot of them drank beer so they
still have that big of water issues in
in 1770. it was easier for them to make
beer than to sometimes even yeah so so
you have all these dudes they meet up
together and they're all sitting there
and you know Thomas Jefferson and John
Hancock and they're just like I I we
can't go to war I mean I mean I
understand we're going to keep
petitioning the king it's like all right
a round of drinks on me but let's keep
talking and then by you know two hours
go by I wouldn't declare independence
standing on tables everybody gets guns
and they're like yeah and they're
fighting I can honestly say this doesn't
scare me as much because
um they got their fingers in everything
and and partly I count on the
incompetence of government like they're
going to collect a bunch of data it's
going to sit there
um I I don't think the good thing is our
system is built to withstand this unlike
Germany and Austria and Australia
everyone else I I get I'm not saying
it's not a threat it is a threat it's
not going to happen here and I'm I'm not
saying that to make people lacks or we
got to take it seriously but but I I
really believe our our system is going
to withstand this there's not the
political will in any the let's face it
the Biden Administration is floundering
do they really want to pick this battle
now say that you can't you can't travel
at all like they're terrified that the
economy no they're not though if you
look doing some some stuff
internationally that they're doing I
oppose all of it don't get me wrong I I
think they're terrified I I don't think
they're stupid enough to do to to go
down this road if at the beginning of
covid right if someone sat you down and
said everything's going to happen the
way it did would you believe them before
covet would with how far the government
has already intervened in our lives how
much they have already taken from us but
how much they already locked us down
which how much they destroyed this
boosters were conspiracy theory yeah no
if someone if someone set you down
before Covenant began and said the
government's going to be disinvolved in
your life would you believe them before
covet I I think I would believe what
happened in the United States I'd be
less inclined to believe what we're
seeing in Australia
um and some of those things
um and yeah I mean that's my answer I I
would be shocked there there is the
potential for danger here we should
oppose it we should get angry about it
um but I I think I think our system is
going to Prevail in this case I think
we're going to put the kibosh on this
it's not going to go very far TSA
extends mask mandate for domestic
flights over Omicron coronavirus variant
through mid-march so that's public
transportation domestic flights ships
taxis trains and we've already heard
from fauci that they're adding new
requirements you need a negative test
before boarding an international no
flight and after you get here you gotta
quarantine so they are slowly pushing
this forward but look any smart
desperate nose you can't come out and
say ladies and gentlemen we're going to
lock you in your homes and weld your
doors shut that wouldn't work people
would be like screw off but after two
years I think it's fair to say we are in
the rat hope experiment are you familiar
with it
I don't think I am dude puts rats in
these tubes full of water and they
struggle after 15 minutes they give up
and they drown and die he puts another
group of rats in there they struggle
right as they're giving up he takes them
out dries them off lets him chill Picks
Them Up puts them back in the second
time they go in they swim for 60 hours
believing if I just keep swimming
eventually the hand will save me again
so we go under this lockdown for about a
year and a few months and then they let
it all open everyone's like oh thank
heavens we're getting back to normal and
the economy should be coming back it's
not and then all of a sudden they say oh
no
a new variant now we've got to start
implementing these lockdowns and they're
not going to do it instantly because
people would lose it but I say give it a
few months especially with the midterms
coming up they're going to exploit this
crisis and then they're going to lock us
down harder than we've seen I could be
wrong about it I don't know I'll say
just you know I'll go back to my home
state I live in Minnesota Twin Cities
we're not we're not you know I won't say
we're a blue state but we're certainly a
purple State you know Governor Tim Walls
was recently the you know getting
questions like why aren't you going
under an emergency lockdown and and he
gave an answer that was incredibly
honest like he didn't you know he he
really implied that that politics had
something to do with it now he also said
there's no evidence that says this will
be you know effective another emergency
order
um I I think you know above all else you
know politics is is staying elected and
I think people know that Americans are
are kind of fed up with these policies
um and yeah like the the feds have some
power as far as like what they can
monitor you know vaccines in
international travel and things
I just partly I'm trying to be
optimistic here I don't want to be too
Doom and Gloom you know like we're not
Australia yet and I I don't think we're
going to be because
um Americans have wised up a lot we have
guns and it makes a big difference in
the last 18 months I think Americans
have kind of awoken I hate to say that
you are right you are right I actually I
recorded a segment on this earlier that
uh Democrat pollsters are basically
sending you know red flags up saying
we're going to lose in 2022 and the
reason is the economy is the most
important issue number one and Democrats
aren't talking about it the lockdowns
seriously impact the economy but in
Virginia one pollster said it wasn't
critical race Theory certainly that had
some of an some some of an impact but it
was the coveted restrictions on schools
parents were already struggling due to
the lockdowns now their kids are back at
home and they're trying to figure out
nannies or who's going to watch the kids
and they got really angry about it so
because of their their push towards this
is why I think there's a good possibly
they might not because they know if they
do this the American people have already
said no way
I think they're still going to maintain
this path because of social media
pressures and so long as Republicans
don't do anything stupid like voting on
you know a bill to create a vaccine
database which they did and they
shouldn't be supporting that it's
ridiculous and anybody that did like you
know if I was one of their constituents
I'd be writing them a letter but that's
what they're doing they don't care about
the letters they care about the big
multinational corporations that really
call the shots here and they will
appease them they will bow down they
will get on their knees I have no hope
for the Republicans when they take over
I have no hope in Dan Crenshaw Mitt
Romney list Cheney and the party of
rollover let let our soft bellies be
shown to the globalists as of course we
sell out our constituents as the hope
that we're going to be something better
when we're just going to be the same
thing with a different color behind it
I'm so sick of it we should be appalled
that the US government shut down small
businesses while allowing Walmart Costco
and all these other big box stores
Amazon to do whatever they wanted to
they destroyed and have created the
largest transfer of wealth recorded
human history robbing poor people blind
enriching the billionaire class and if
we think they're not capable of doing
what Australia is doing to its people I
think we're not paying attention I think
we're at a at a moment where there are
they are itching for a new tragedy to
exploit and they will use anything
manufacture or anything or even do
anything to create this tragedy at this
particular moment in order to get their
way I could like I Echo most of that but
here's what I will say like I don't
trust you know a republican any more
than a than a Democrat for the most part
at the same time I as a Libertarian like
we gridlock is good we want gridlock
gridlock if you look at you know
historically at spending and other
metrics we can use you know when when
there's gridlock in Congress well a lot
less bad stuff happen but it's not
gridlock the Republicans were on board
with every agenda pushed against the
American people especially when covet
came they were like yes Dr fauci's great
whatever Dr fauci wants Dr fauci gets uh
14 days to sold their spread a great
idea and Republicans didn't even bat an
eye didn't give a damn about their
constituents their people they said back
the blue support police officers as they
bust down your door and shut down your
business that's ridiculous and for
people to still believe that they're
going to change anything I think it's
naive in my personal opinion but I may
be I may be too black people no I I hey
there there's reason for cynicism and
and I don't you're not wrong that the
GOP what did they do for us in 2020
um not a heck of a lot
um so so I I hear where you're coming
from but I have no you know
misconceptions
um next year if Republicans take the
house if they take the Senate is
everything going to change well we'll
know but gridlock is good if there is a
primary Red Wave and everybody who
watches this goes and tells 10 of their
friends and family to vote in the
primaries then you will get something
special come November because all of a
sudden you're gonna have a whole bunch
of you know populists being like all
that established crap is out let's get
dark with it I don't know let's let's go
pessimistic we have this story from
harvard.edu Harvard youth poll finds
Young Americans are worried about
democracy and even fearful of Civil War
oh you know I love to say it they say
more than half of Young Americans feel
democracy in the country is under threat
and over a third think they may see a
second U.S Civil War within their
lifetimes according to the 42nd Harvard
youth poll released by Harvard Kennedy
schools Institute of Politics the poll
also found approval for President Biden
has plummeted and a majority of
respondents are unhappy with how the
president and Congress are doing their
jobs I think it's funny that you're
asking young people it's like how do you
feel about Congress and they're like
well I've realized they're bad it's like
it's because you're getting older and
you're watching them but older people
have been watching them for a long time
knowing they're bad I love that Joe
Biden's approval rating is tanking but I
knew who Joe Biden was back during
Occupy Wall Street 10 years ago all
these young people are like kind of
fueloko was lied to about joke Biden but
we've got this other one that wraps
along with it hedge fund founder Ray
dalio predicts there is a 30 percent
chance of U.S Civil War in the next 10
years because of emotional political
polarization believes the Constitution
May save the nation
now I think the issue is there's two
realities
and I think you know most people we talk
to agree certainly some people say no
it's not true but I think if you talk to
um
you talk to some of these these
Democrats they'll tell you Russia gate
still happened like even though we know
and we've known for years Trump did not
collude with Russia they still believe
it things like that if you have people
who uh we had an article from Slate the
uh no Salon I'm sorry Salon the other
day yeah that's sad the second Civil War
may come like which side are you on
choose your side now and they said they
uh are multi-racial democracy is
anathema to the Republican party or like
the Republican View and I'm like that's
insane Republicans are not that that is
not what they are but if you have people
who live in that world then yeah I I
agree we're heading in that direction
and it's not just my opinion it's the
opinion of a guy who hedge fund founder
whose job is literally to make
predictions about where these markets
are going to go and he thinks it's a
good chance it could happen now we
should right away say okay what do we
mean by Civil War yeah oh I think we're
in one already and what I mean by that
is it's a fourth and fifth generational
War which is propaganda information
Warfare economic Warfare so we have had
ground skirmishes we've had we've had
had antifa fighting with proud boys who
had right wing groups clashing with
left-wing groups we've had Insurgency
there was a guy who shot to a nice
facility with a ghost gun and some
firebombs there was a dude who went and
executed a trump supporter in the middle
of the street in Portland a lot of
things like that that's the
Congressional baseball game that was
shot up as well that's right there's
yeah that's right yeah and so that was a
Bernie volunteer who did that and um
Steve scalise almost lost his life I
could see like a corporate uh War like
the corporations versus everybody else
and that happening in the United States
is like a Battleground for it
unfortunately that's already happening
but like a hot War the corporations have
like private military and but where
would they locate their bases they have
their corporate headquarters they could
use they probably own a lot of land that
they would use
I don't I don't I don't but other than
that I don't see the American people
going out corporations are not
ideological for the most part they're
being infiltrated by ideological
individuals Schwab is the ideologue but
he's he's something far beyond just a
corporation he's Davos group he wants
corporations to run the world I think
we're living in a world where ideas are
more powerful than bullets and I think
those ideas and that kind of form of
manipulation is something that has been
used already in a war that we don't even
know exists right now that has hurt
tremendously the populations of this
world and I think I think this guy is is
right I think his assessment is fair but
I think it's going to hedge more on the
prominence of social media so if social
media is as prominent and becomes more
prominent in our lives I do believe the
likelihood of civil war is going to go
up if social media becomes less
prominent it's not going to be as
prominent that's what I personally
believe because when we look at big Tech
algorithms when we look at the
prominence of social media you see hyper
polarization of people on the political
Spectrum going into their Echo Chambers
more and more and more and the algorithm
regurgitates it and I think deliberately
pushes it this is my own Theory towards
a divide and conquer agenda that has
people fighting each other rather than
looking at the true source of their
problems that's really creating it
that's my personal perspective and
opinion but if we get rid of social
media I'm not saying get rid of it I'm
saying the prominence so social media
becomes more prominent so so look our
show is
prominence of social media that people
choose to go to YouTube or Twitter or
Facebook or whatever else to get content
they find channels like ours we're not
on TV so certainly this is what big Tech
big the big machine The Establishment
wants they want to homogenize everything
they have slowly been removing people
from YouTube and if you search on
YouTube for news what are you gonna get
if you if you typed in like you know
something like Germany uh unvaxed
lockdown you ain't gonna get us you're
not gonna get my channels timcast
timcast news Tim castler ain't gonna
happen you're gonna get CNN ABC NBC
MSNBC Etc even though we know they lie
we still have Joe Rogan is the number
one show on Spotify like which we just
saw there's an appetite people can go
find their shows that they want and
that's good for now but as far as the
Civil War though just to chime in like
we hear Civil War we think of 1861 right
we we have As Americans it was the most
pivotal moment in our history maybe more
so than even Independence it's
um it's ingrained in our fiber in our
history
um we're not going to see that I I don't
think that's you know so we might have a
civil war it's not going to look like
that
um I like to think I might have
mentioned this to Lydia earlier I like
to think of it maybe as a brexit right
um that we just you know like we might
say this isn't working out and you know
like trying to maybe rule like from
Washington DC a bunch of corrupt
politicians where our our words are the
law and we're going to rule the whole
nation which is very diverse by the way
we have different cultures different
people different Traditions they trying
to to govern everybody under one
umbrella to me doesn't make a lot of
sense anymore I think the framers would
say yeah this isn't working
um I think they'd look and say you know
what what is the purpose of government
it's to protect life liberty and
property that government's really not
doing that I think some of them might
say that yeah it got out of hand uh the
representatives they used to represent I
don't know a few thousand people 30 000
and now I don't know seven hundred
thousand fifty seven hundred fifty
thousand people one guy supposed to
represent you can barely represent
yourself effectively uh that's your
number one job so I think Democratic
republicanism is is dying and and we
need a new form where you can't have
republics uh you can't have these people
that get voted in and get bribed that's
what over and over and over whether it's
a new face or an old face they're
getting money from Exxon and all these
crazy corporations alphabet Pfizer
Pfizer and it's like a it's like a it's
like a a point of weakness of
vulnerability in the system these these
bribes that keep happening it wouldn't
matter though right if the politicians
didn't have the power they have
um like all those bribes that they
happen because there's so much at stake
because they have so much power if we
remove the power from the politicians
that's much less of a problem and and we
have a mechanism to do that we have you
know if you look in in recent history
it's not just brexit other places have
said you know what this isn't working
um and for I think for Americans that's
a really hard idea I don't think we're
close to that idea but you know at Fe
our motto anything peaceful right and if
we just you know like as Americans say
you know we had a good run the marriage
it's not really working out you go your
way we're going to go our way and if if
people in it's not I'm not saying that's
practical I think it's it's very painful
no I think it would be hard but but I I
think that approach
it makes sense I so we've had the
conversation about peaceful divorce or
national divorce quite a bit but I think
a lot of people who are proponents of
this don't understand that like
California for instance their their
Southern California is completely
dependent upon the Colorado River so if
we all start going our separate ways and
California's blue and they break off
Colorado is going to be like you know
we're gonna you know you want our water
let's let's negotiate we're no longer
part of the same system and it's going
to change things they could cut them off
they could start polluting you know
Upstream California might get mad you've
got states that think they have a right
to the Great Lakes let's talk about you
know uh Pennsylvania the fracking Fields
the amount of energy they produce in in
Western Pennsylvania well the
surrounding states need that energy all
of a sudden they break off and the trade
how is it going to function what are the
rules where the laws like we're seeing
with brexit I'm not saying it's it's an
it's it's the bad outweighs the good I'm
just saying what I think might end up
happening is you've got Eastern Oregon
wanting to break away from Western
Oregon
Western Oregon won't allow that they're
wealthy they're powerful that's the
center of power and the people in the
East they pay them they're effectively
the serfs in the in the fields they're
not gonna let them go so the question I
guess is if we do see National divorce
do you think that the the overwhelmingly
dense deep red areas within a blue state
will just be like guess we're going with
the far left on this one or are they
going to be like no way if if the if the
Republican Red State conservative
independent libertarian whatever group
is breaking away we want to join them
well you're surrounded by Blue States
you may be Southern Illinois completely
red
but too many too much blue all around
you what do you do no fighting starts it
would be messy like if you I brought up
the American Civil War earlier that was
kind of clean even though there's a lot
of Bloodshed in the fact that you had a
one boundary right you had the Mason
Dixon line and I know that there were
some states that weren't necessarily of
the south north of that but that's not
the point today we have different
divides
um and it's you know some of it's Urban
Rural right like so so this wouldn't be
easy it would be messy
um and you bring up a lot of as far as
trade water rights mineral rights
um all of that you know but it's
preferable I think to either a real war
a real Civil War or living under a
government that's increasingly
tyrannical and that's what I see but it
precipitates War so you have you know
Upstate New York a lot of which is more
conservative more libertarian you know
not interested in what the New York City
is doing and let's say they uh they you
know people the over majority of people
in Upstate New York are like nah you're
in New Jersey I don't know what you're
doing so you're out because it's real
it's Urban versus rural do you think
like New York is just going to be like I
guess we'll die no they're going to be
like you can't do this open the roads up
you can't ID us we're in New York and
then it's not instant if there was some
kind of you know Convention of states
and then everyone said okay that's it
we're breaking up and then we'll
negotiate how this goes Eastern Oregon
is going to be like no and what are they
going to do are they going to come in if
look if Eastern Oregon is faced with the
possibility of the country breaking
apart they'll immediately be like we're
with them and Oregon and Washington and
these states are going to be like nah
but then they're backed up by Idaho what
happens when the food isn't coming what
happens when California which produces a
large amount of food for this country
all of a sudden is under completely
different rules that and then what
happens if the overwhelmingly leftists
in the government start seizing land and
pulling off stupid BS
worst case scenario we get invaded by an
external force and then the history book
writes it as that was the moment the U.S
was destroyed
you're not the first person that brought
that up I think that's an overblown fear
I think nothing would unite Americans
more than an international Force trying
to you know get in our backyard
um you know as far as like an example
like Oregon the good thing is there are
even I I'm not usually some of that
quotes International precedent but we do
have ever you know right to the U.N
people have a right to declare
independence and if if people over there
decide you know what this isn't working
out we there are steps to take to do
that like I said I don't think we're
there right now I think Americans have
to go they must they're going to be
pushed much further but when I look at
the long-term picture of things and I've
never talked about this publicly it was
just you know stuff you chew on in the
shower or something like like this isn't
really working out like like what what's
in it what's the off ramp where is it
well this is something that I was
talking about last year when I first
came on the show one of the first things
I brought up was peaceful divorce who
need a peaceful divorce and we need more
memes in the larger Spectrum if you
remember the first episode that's what I
was kind of going on about but we have
to remember there's two factors here one
the state is becoming more and more
sociopathic they don't only just want
their pound of Flesh where they
literally create ideas like civil asset
forfeiture which is insane but they want
to tax you they want to regulate you
they want to control every aspect of
your existence towards a crazy maniacal
level and throughout human history
Communists have never peacefully allowed
separation they have wanted to control
everything and every aspect of your
existence and it's sick and it's twisted
and it totally destroys any form of
progress but there are instances just
like with the Amish where people do come
together and say this is crazy I don't
want to be a part of this and they are
respected as their own individual entity
which I believe individuals and groups
like The free state project are trying
to make their own kind of Amish group in
New Hampshire and I think what they're
doing is is amazing I think they have a
lot of success stories and I think it is
possible on that small micro level but I
think what's really going to be likely
is that economically financially
socially it there's going to be a huge
storm coming and when that storm comes
people are going to come together and
they're going to live together and
that's going to be their own individual
groups and they're going to be
identified as their own power structures
I think that is way more likely and
there might be clashes between power
structures and that might be deemed a
civil war but I think that is more of a
likely situation than one of the old
kind of knowledge the north versus the
South which is Impractical and if we
look at historically other civil wars
it's not just territorial regions it's
people fighting over ideas and I think
that's that's going to happen on on many
levels when everything hits the fan and
this is the real uh I think the
potential Catalyst we have is I don't
know which side has a stronger moral
stance you have the left and wokism
which is a non-theistic religion or cult
whatever you want to call it and these
people are willing to burn down and
murder they've burned down buildings 25
people dead in the George Floyd rights
and when Aaron Danielson is shot in the
chest in Portland they cheered for on
more than one occasion so these people
celebrate the death of their perceived
enemies now the right doesn't do that
they're not and there's still a strong
moral position and that's abortion so I
wonder you know what we saw in 1861 was
a strong moral position that was a
strong Catalyst for the War slavery
abolitionists were like we will storm in
full speed to envis
with wokism
they're com they're going around saying
white supremacy they're they're doing
rallies right now where they claim that
white supremacy is defending itself of
Kyle Rittenhouse and all that stuff but
you also have right now the Supreme
Court issuing or I'm sorry hearing their
oral hearing the oral arguments on the
Mississippi 15-week abortion ban and a
belief among many in the media and many
leftists that come June 2022 abortion
will be banned that will ignite Insanity
among the left
and the right will absolutely stand by
the defendant with these trigger laws
happening with blue States then
reinforcing you're going to have a hard
ideological divide between woke and
unwoke and that could be a potential
Catalyst or the very least
if we're talking about you know Tinder
being thrown into the fire and the
Flames slowly getting bigger June 2020
if the Supreme Court does overturn Roe v
Wade it'll be like someone just threw a
whole drum of gasoline right on top of
it it doesn't mean it'll spark a war it
just means it's gonna get hot
yeah no there will be a lot of Fury and
anger and gnashing of teeth might but I
will say my prediction is
um I do think it will happen I don't
think it'll be now this is a bold
prediction oh boy I don't think it'll be
as big of a deal as you think the Civil
Ware yeah if they overturn Roe vs Wade
um it'll be we'll talk about it a lot
there'll be like I said gnashing of
teeth but we've we've been here for so
long
um I I think it's going to be it's gonna
make social media crazy I don't think
it's going to be like what we saw in
2020. uh and that's my hope so you think
we're on the back end we're heading down
nothing's going to slow down and even
yeah if you look across demographics
um I think I think abortion is kind of a
losing battle for um for Democrats I
think progressives hold to it
religiously
um but you know like they're gonna
they're gonna get really loud and angry
about it but they're not the people that
are gonna get most loud and angry aren't
the people that are going to go marching
in streets it well they'll March don't
get me wrong they'll March um but
they're not the people that are going to
light up cars and and do that this is
Whoopi Goldberg I did today which there
was a great response Olivia rondu had a
great response to that and she said well
well Whoopi just you know pretty much
said that men can have children like
that that men can't you know like like
Whoopi Goldberg
we have this here from Fox News The View
host will be Goldberg erupts an abortion
debate how dare men talk about what a
fetus wants ex-conservative Anna Navarro
on conservative majority and Supreme
Court be careful what you wish for
so Whoopi Goldberg she was making like a
like an anti-trans argument is that what
she was well she was like hands off my
body doc yeah but she's implying that
men can't have children by saying this
right and that's kind of verboten in at
least in some context well she's she's
an old school liberal she doesn't
understand the new cult and what they
believe and everything like that so so
she's all for her body but she's also a
pro-vaccine a mandatory vaccine if I
don't want to judge this too much
because I didn't watch the entire thing
I watched like a 30-40 seconds of it and
she was fired up this this really this
really bugs me too even on even on a
Surface she said do any of you men have
any eggs or the possibility of carrying
a fetus how dare you talk about what a
fetus wants you have no idea I'm fine if
you disagree with abortion I have no
problem with that my problem comes you
tell me what I need to do with my doctor
and my family how dare you how dare you
you know uh uh I'm I'm pro-choice and
it's a really it's a if you have to
really break it down to like its
philosophical route to understand what I
mean by that because I certainly don't
agree with the left they're pro-abortion
it's very very different things have
changed so I can understand some of the
righteous indignation but men certainly
have a right to an argument in the
debate that's absurd it takes a man and
woman to make a child and it's also
nightmarish when you see stories there
was one video I watched where a guy is
like following this woman into an
abortion clinic screaming please don't
kill my son please stop please he drops
to his knees and he's crying out in
front of it and she's just like get away
from me and that's that's like yeah man
this is not an easy
um moral situation these are these are
deeply philosophical questions and
they're questions that government can't
solve you know I I am pro-life I'm
deeply pro-life
um but I understand the limitations of
government fixing this problem the truth
is if you have somebody that wants to
terminate their baby
um I don't think I don't think they
should have the right to do that because
they're they're they're taking life
that's not peaceful
um at the same time I I recognize that
um you know compelling someone to carry
a child they don't want is going to to
end up poorly that situation is going to
be bad it's really tough because I think
there there's there's so many uh
people's perspectives on it are very
very different you know when I was
talking with Sheamus uh uh Freedom Tunes
his view was very much that the word
abortion means the needless termination
of a pregnancy and my view on it is any
circumstance in which a doctor
terminates the life of of the baby and
so to me that could mean serious mental
health issue I'm sorry not not mental
serious health issues for the mother and
the child and a decision that has to
come from a medical doctor and the woman
and to Sheamus the argument was
literally like people using abortion as
contraception or just deciding they want
don't want to take risks and so I don't
want to uh I'm not trying to
um diminish his total argument because
you know because I was about to go
head-to-head with it he's not here right
right that's what I'm saying right I
don't want to put words in his mouth
because he's not here to defend himself
we we had a big discretion out we
disagree like a miscarriage is a type of
abortion so I it is yeah they call it
involuntary abortion because the fetus
is aborted it's involuntarily on it you
know not against the word involuntary is
the big part there right right right so
um you know we talked about this quite a
bit yesterday when we were discussing
Roe v Wade and um how the Supreme Court
it seems like they're leaning towards
overturning it or effectively
overturning it with the ruling on the
Mississippi uh uh uh abortion ban but we
here's what we should talk about like
when you overturning Roe versus way
doesn't end abortion right it just means
that the federal that that's some states
are going to have it and some are not
and that that solution won't please
everyone either
um but it is much more of a
it'll be it'll be more what was intended
from our government like like if you
look there's no abortion's not a
constitutional issue if we if we say
that we live under the U.S Constitution
there's nothing in there that suggests
that the federal government should be
making these decisions yeah I think
Clarence Thomas uh was asking like where
in the constitution does it say this is
a right or something that effect and the
woman argument which I think his name
was wrinkleman uh and she's a solicitor
general and she said and the 14th
Amendment and he's like I can read the
Second Amendment and see what it says
like what are you referring to right and
he made a really good point it is to me
an insane argument that it's a
constitutional right to get an abortion
that that she said it's it's it's it's
seated in life life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness or something that
it's a liberty argument
and I'm like you know my view is
there's a very serious challenge in what
the government should be allowed to do
when it comes to you know people's
medical decisions and their bodies and
the issue with abortion that I think the
left
willfully ignores is that the baby is a
life the mother is alive they're both
valid it's it's annoying to me when I
see there's like a meme going around
from these leftists and they're like
it's actually someone I know posted this
saying the argument about whether or not
a fetus is a life is the wrong argument
the real argument is whether a woman is
a life and I'm like that what do you
even see you don't even saying anything
look I get it women are alive and the
babies are alive or trying to figure out
how to do this right you're not helping
by making these nonsensical statements
that's a bad argument even I think most
people that are pro-abortion would admit
that's a bad argument now they're
posting these memes I'm just like look
man it's really scared me the idea that
the government is given precedent for
being involved in medical decisions and
and I'm like that's the challenge of
abortion is that the the to a certain
for a certain amount of time the fetus
is dependent upon the mother and now
you've got gov government intervention
in America I don't like it I don't like
vaccine passports I don't like vaccine
mandates I don't like any kind of
mandate you know what I mean for medical
choices it shouldn't be something the
government's involved in and so that's a
very rudimentary thing I see
and then I see what ends what you get
when the left actually wins there here's
what happens the left comes in and says
see shouldn't we have pro-choice and
then someone like me goes yeah and they
go great hey everybody you can use
abortion as contraception now and I'm
like no what no and then that's what
they end up doing and so then it's just
there's no middle like to me it's still
so philosophical and there's no you know
like it's just clearly wrong to me but
again it gets messy trying to have laws
to fix these things one of my first
stories ever as a newspaper reporter
years ago as a cub reporter the Panama
City News Herald in Florida and a young
woman probably less than 25 years old
um was she she murdered her baby and
that that was just just born I think
it's been a lot many years but she just
left it I think she might have drowned
it in the bathroom or something and I
and I covered that did a couple of
Stories on it
um as far as I remember I think she went
to prison for life or like a really long
time
um but if she would done it a week
earlier I remember thinking if she was
done a week earlier it's perfectly legal
that's right um and and so like you
can't you know trying to have government
have solutions to this
um you know like it it gets messy but
um as an individual I just say like no
it's it's life and and the one thing the
government is supposed to do is protect
life so well here's where I think look
we've uh I wanna I'll go back to what
we're talking about with Civil War stuff
and you were saying that you know you
don't think it'll be that bad I actually
I think that I don't the right way to
describe this I completely disagree we
have seen non-stop escalation and no
sign of it slowing down if I were to ask
you in 2014
do you think that in 2020 a thousand
right-wing individuals would Storm Into
the capital interrupting the Electoral
College proceedings resulting in 10
months of solitary confinement and the
expansion of the Capitol Police
Nationwide you'd be like shut up if I
said in in you know in a few years
there's going to be roving bands of far
left extremists burning down buildings
and killing people and a guy is going to
get shot in the chest and murdered you
would tell me to shut up and I know this
because this is literally what happened
when I said it was going to happen back
in 2017 2018 when I was covering the the
street violence I was talking to people
pundits politicos Libertarians DC types
and I was saying like guys I see this
getting worse it's only getting worse
and they were like oh shut up the state
would never allow this to escalate
Beyond The Proud Boys in antifa No One's
Gonna Die they're larpers and then sure
enough dude walks up to Aaron Nelson and
just puts two in his chest for no reason
and we we have seen consistently
escalating violence to the point where
even after January 6 I don't think it
was an Insurrection I think it was a
riot I think it was bad some of these
people the doors were open they were let
in still really bad I still have people
walk up and be like do you think it's
going to be a Civil War and now what
happens I say January 6 and they go oh
yeah so you think about January 6. not
as insane as the Democrats think it is
but hey from their perspective troubling
if these people want to come out and
simultaneously criticize me for saying I
think a civil war is his strong
potential but then also claim they want
to criticize me for saying that but then
also claim January 6 was an Insurrection
I'm like what was wrong about what I
said then if you agree with if you
believe that now what happens come June
2022 if we get another major culture War
catalyst there's no sign of this slowing
down for any reason right now it's
winter winter things you know are chill
this happened last year people were like
ah it's cold out we're not going to see
a rise and then January 6 happened so
what happens come springtime especially
June 2022 they overturned Roe v Wade man
you are going to see riots and it's
going to escalate and now with Kyle
Rittenhouse and the self-defense
precedence and a lot of things we've
seen the left is arguing that they need
to bring their guns out
they need to bring their guns out
because the right's going to bring their
guns out we've already had we had two
shootouts in Portland I think only a
couple months ago it's the craziest
thing to me that people are like nah I
think things are chilling out I'm like
dude it's been a month of winter and
that's why you're saying that a couple
months ago we had someone on the show
and I was like we had two shootouts in
Portland literally left and right wing
groups shooting at each other in the
street we had a guy driving his truck
and antifa blockaded the street and
aimed rifles at the guy in his truck and
he pulled out his gun and pointed it at
them and I'm like
why would I believe this is slowing down
now we got a midterm year and they're
saying the Republicans Republicans are
going to sweep yo we already had people
burn down buildings across this country
killing 25. why would it get any better
no it's a good question and I I don't
want to minimize the violence that that
we're experiencing or that we saw in you
know on January 6th or or before that
which in my opinion like like you know
you find yourself January 6th with bad
what we saw before that was much worse
to me it was much more because the
difference was I look at DC they're they
got cops everywhere now again like like
they weren't there that day like things
were things were bad but I look at shop
owners that were everything that they've
built is being destroyed nobody was
looking after them we had as you said 25
people died it was it was the bloodiest
civil unrest that we've had since the
60s so so the I I don't minimize that
but these people then went and voted for
Joe Biden
which which people in these big cities
they went blue they went hard blue yeah
these people these people Kamala Harris
who was soliciting donations to bail the
rioters out Joe Biden 13 of his staff
members helped bail the rioters out and
the people in Minnesota said blue no
matter who people would actually say
that blue no matter who I'm like what is
going on think about what you're doing
before you do it so it was it was
incredibly dangerous like like that I
remember being infuriated by that like
like here's the thing you know
Rittenhouse got GoFundMe shut down it's
one guy accused of a crime you actually
know the details when you when you're
just giving money to a bunch of people
that have been arrested for all this
violent crime that to me is I found it
really troubling so what do you think
happens come uh 2023 When Donald Trump
uh not even 23 maybe maybe maybe this
next year towards the end of the year
Trump says I am officially announcing I
am running Lord help us yeah what you
think these people are just gonna be
like you know what
I've been my whole life let's say let's
say uh Donald Trump gets elected uh you
know five years ago
uh just about five years ago and you've
got someone who's 15 years old and so
they're growing up in the Trump era
hearing nothing in the Press but Trump
is evil he's a Nazis a fascist and must
be stopped a few years ago go by and now
they're 19 and they're like I'm going to
vote a lot of young people now these
people are being told and they're as
they're entering their early to mid-20s
Donald Trump is running again this is it
the end of democracy whatever you not
only have the entire faction of antifa
who were College age kids up to you know
adult men the guy who attacked the ice
facility was in his 40s now you've got
with with another three years another
set of teenagers who are 15 who are
watching all this go down and they're
aging Into The Fray more and more
ideologues are being pulled in as we
speak and in three years 15 year olds
will be 18 they will issue their votes I
think Trump's going to announce you're
going to have 16 17 year olds Hearing in
the media screeching louder than you've
ever seen especially as the media is
dying out their ratings are in the
gutter they're going to be like we must
Embrace this more than we've ever
embraced it and they're going to get
violent add this to the Dismal economic
Outlook and more people becoming poorer
and more people have no economic
opportunities it's only going to make
the situation that much worse not just
with crime in big urban areas but
nationally all throughout the United
States the Middle America has already
been gutted by big Pharma in the opioid
epidemic but I truly believe a lot of
this is orchestrated a lot of this is
plan and whether it's done on purpose or
whether it's incentivized by Big Money
uh for for Pure profit reasons I think
it starts on the micro level on the
internet with algorithms amplifying
escalating fights and drama and I think
that's how it started off and I think
it's slowly escalating into this huge
snowball that some people are calling
the Civil War some people are calling
this Left Right divide and conquer
scheme I I see this done deliberately
and as we fight each other we never
truly solve the problems that are really
plaguing us just two points like first
I'll I'll bet you a bottle of Scotch
that that Donald Trump doesn't run again
if you want we can talk we can talk
terms afterwards we've talked to some
former staffers who have said you
probably got better information than me
I'm I'm going just on my my guess on
Trump
um but more like like I here's here's
the serious thing I I think we are
seeing that we have seen the re The
Rebirth of fascism in America like in
America for the first time if you if you
go back and if you read what was
happening in Europe in in the 1920s
1930s fascism has finally arrived to the
United States
um it's it's exists on both the right
and the left is more ascendant right now
in my opinion on the left and and it
frightens me more frankly
um and so yeah like I think in the near
term it's going to be the the violence
we're seeing is part of that if you look
you know Orwell said the word fascism
he's like it's useless because it's just
it's just a slur now it doesn't right we
forgot what the word means but if you
look at what fascism really meant
um you know for one it it meant this
idea that we we're all one that you know
the Italian word you know fassie means
it's a bundle of rods and that it's the
opposite of liberalism which just says
yeah you can go your way we're going to
go our way but when you look at like
it's implementation
that the fascists were all about
blurring the lines of public and private
life they wanted it they didn't see a
difference if it didn't serve the the
public interest you know like they had
no interest for private behavior that
didn't serve it that's the Democrat so
so that's where we're arriving at that
point and it's it's kind of frightening
um but we've seen darker times Liberty
has seen darker times fee for example is
founded 1946 1946 take just pause for a
minute and think what 1946 looked like
the the Communists were a global Empire
um like they were they were power hungry
they were going everywhere we you know
our ideas are better we we have
platforms to share them on
um we need to persuade people don't go
down this road don't go down this road
of of you know toxic ideology where
where you you put where you empower the
state to run your lives in this fashion
the challenge I see is that um you know
we we we try to get left us on the show
Perry radically but it's it's really
hard but we have had vosh we've had
Destiny we've had Jen Perlman we've had
a variety of people who are Libertarians
many who are hard leftists a few yeah I
mentioned them yeah and uh but mostly we
get Libertarians moderates conservatives
and like I think libertarian is probably
the best way to put it maybe not Big L
but just people who are typically like
here's the news I understand what's real
the problem is you know we we do this
show with uh with a variety of voices I
mean Luke is very libertarian he doesn't
like to I don't like that word uh I'm
not saying I'm not saying Big Al he's
you're a freedom guy yeah yeah he's a
freedom guy and he's ragged on Trump the
entirety of Trump's uh Administration he
was never a trump Maga guy the worst
trolling I've ever had on on Twitter was
was Mega people that's an issue with one
of my tweets sliming Trump
um but you know like I it's kind of a
badge of honor you gotta slam people
when they're wrong I got ruthlessly
attacked by them and it was fine and I
welcomed it and I welcomed the Battle of
ideas it freaked me out it's the first
time that happened to me so here's the
issue the the the the crisis that we're
facing is a crisis of realities two
different universes colliding at least
two my my economic it's funny when
people get in debates on Twitter over
whether or not I'm leftist or
conservative because all conservatives
like Tim's clearly a leftist but I agree
with the right for the most part on
what's reality so when they say Trump
colluded with Russia I'm like well
that's completely false I fact check it
conservatives are like yes that's
correct too because we've also looked
into it but many of these establishment
leftists believe something nonsensical
so what happens is
on this Joe we just try to be correct
we're not always right we also try to
make sure our labels are correct so I'll
say something like leftists are
pro-second Amendment that's a fact
Liberals are not but in a lot a lot of
times you hear the debate it's broken
down to the left hates guns and the
right loves guns I'm like no socialists
love guns too Karl Marx said you know
under no pretext that famous quote
so we tried we try but we also point out
I think it's fair to say when you follow
the facts you will see the Democratic
party is the Bastion of fascism today in
America with many Republicans as well
through the establishment you have the
Lincoln project which were these former
Republican you know big shots and they
fled to the Democrats because Trump
barged his way in Trump is not a fascist
in my opinion and I think what Trump
represented was National populism which
kind of upended the establishment
political parties which which you do
have a tendency towards fascism but then
you end up with many of the leftists
blindly supporting Democrats because
they live in different reality so when
you get
um Australia is a good example and my
Feud on Twitter with like Claire Lehman
where I'm like the guardian has reported
this
abc.net.au has reported this and I say
and say hey it's really bad that they're
taking people and putting them in camps
but then you have people who genuinely
believe I made that up so I went on Joe
Rogan and I remember seeing uh you know
this got posted on Twitter whatever and
one of the comments was I'm 45 minutes
in and it's very obvious this guy Tim
Poole is making all of this stuff up
what what and that's because they live
in a different a totally different
reality so if you believe Colette and
you don't read the news it's crazy to
believe that the the Australian Defense
Force was deployed in the Northern
Territory and is assisting with setting
up checkpoints and taking people by army
truck indigenous people to quarantine
camps but that's not my reporting that's
the guardian I mean the guardian's
supposed to be some great Outlet well
some people don't live in reality and
because of that they believe things that
aren't true they get angry they get
violent and then they say you're evil
and I'll fight you how do you deal with
that it's not an issue of my policy
positions not pro-choice I'm I'm fairly
economically left libertarian but that's
totally meaningless if the actual
progressives don't agree on what is real
like uh we were just looking at
something from Kyle kolinsky and we'll
jump in a second where he's claiming
Dave Rubin got some guy banned on
Twitter with no evidence and I'm just
like I I would never report that because
I would need verifiable evidence proving
that Dave Rubin actually sent someone to
get someone banned off the internet but
they will report it as true now
certainly we all have our faults as well
we get things wrong too so I don't want
to you know I I think Kyle klinsky does
a good job but when you have russiagate
for years when you have Rachel Maddow
doubling doubling doubling down and it's
not true and they still don't let it go
after every bit of evidence proves them
wrong I don't know how you Rectify a
group of people who are willing to burn
down buildings kill people while
believing insane stuff like this
uh how how do you solve for that no like
it's the most terrifying part and I
don't know when it started but but we
lived today in alternate universes as
you say it there's another I'll go back
to Orwell he had a great quote
um he was I think he wrote it in the
early 40s he was reflecting on his
experience in the in the Spanish Civil
War and he said everything since 1936 is
propaganda and he said he the guy with
him nodded and and and and then he
explained he's like look I I've you know
I've from an early age I saw there's
nothing ever written in a newspaper that
was true he said but you know it was
during war he said we're truth
completely it was it was obliterated he
didn't use that word uh but he explained
it far more poetically and when it's one
of the things I thought of like in in
these recent years when you're when
you're watching a CNN clip and they're
describing a mostly peaceful protest
while while burning buildings are
burning in the background
um it's troubling when you when you see
this like where where truth is going
um sultanistan talked about the same
thing during war truth dies again I'm
paraphrasing
um but you mentioned this I hadn't
thought of this when you said we're
already in a war
um I never thought of it that way but in
in maybe one sense we are and and when
when that is happening truth there's no
place for truth and people that's that
care about it that actually you know if
you you you tweet something wrong you go
fix it you remove it you apologize you
know when we're in the business of
reporting you get things wrong and and
you try to you know you correct it we if
you do this long enough you'll make
those mistakes what scares me is we kind
of stopped doing that media doesn't go
and and fix a lot of these mistakes
anymore they do occasionally but
um it is troubling like like we we live
in you know I'll bring up salts and
eatston again live not by lies and I see
lies everywhere today and and I find it
you know deeply troubling it's one of
the reasons you know you looked at me
you know like as a person that might you
know say well it's not so bad I was more
taking issue with the Catalyst of being
abortion right I I think there is going
to be a catalyst that's going to cause
some some great civil unrest
um you know I just don't think abortion
will probably be the one
um you know I'm not a prepper but at the
same time I'm moving my family to a more
safe area like I'm like yeah I was
really close to that violence in the
Twin Cities last year was happening I
was up at two in the morning watching
all these buildings burned my family's
sleeping next to me and I it was it was
really troubling the preppers are the
new prophets in our modern society and
the conspiracy theorists are the ones
who literally have been calling things
as they are right now uh it's absolutely
incredible they're troubling times but
we we can get it fixed we have that we
have the right idea we got to repeal the
trade trade act I think since September
11th 2001 we basically it's been a
medium manipulation frenzy getting us
into Iraq I agree I thought of this
today as I was going through like like
the TSA I took a picture even and I said
you know what Bin Laden won like like he
he got killed but but you know what
everything I'm trying to do like like he
brought down
you know this evil empire in a way all
the all the values we had kind of went
out the window in 2000 yeah terrorism
one well the US allowed itself whether
intentionally or unintentionally allowed
itself to become like a semi-terror it
feels like I'm living under so in a sort
of Terror right now so get this
um while you've been talking I've been
trying to pull up this image that shows
the perfect example of the different
realities and uh I can't pull it on so I
I do have some examples but you can see
this on my Instagram oh yeah there's uh
two two uh TV screen two TV screens I
believe it's at a gym on the left it
says Sandlin confirms quid pro quo on
the right it says I want nothing
sondling confirms Trump no print quid
pro quo the reality is and I wrote about
this was that the truth was there was no
quid pro quo that is not so this is in
reference to Trump the impeachment
Ukraine trial it was complete
fabrication lies from The Establishment
and the leftists were in line with them
and they believed Trump did these things
and I think a lot of the Democratic
Socialist types like the actual core
leftists probably it goes over their
head but in this image I can't even pull
it up anymore I basically say Gordon
Sandlin said I personally believe there
was a quid pro quo but Trump said there
wasn't right and my response is okay
well your opinion on what you think may
have happened is not a fact relevant to
the to the impeachment the the question
is what did Trump actually say and Trump
said I want nothing no quid pro quo just
you know go and do this and I can't pull
it up sorry this page is not available I
can show you this however a really good
example I wrote same screen different
movie this is a reference to Scott Adams
quote about everyone's watching the same
screen but seeing two different things
on the left you have Benny Johnson who
said Ted Cruz nukes conspiracy theorist
DNC activist Chuck Todd Chuck Ukraine
was trying to get Hillary Clinton
elected which is what the media wanted
Ukraine meddling is inconvenient to for
your narrative Dems have no evidence of
a crime now you're working for Adam
Schiff on the right is John Harwood a
mainstream media reporter who said Ted
Cruz disseminating propaganda fabricated
by the Kremlin to weaken the U.S
the reality is Benny Johnson a bit
hyperbolic but there's more truth to
what he said Politico reported I believe
it was in January of 2017 that um
elements in Ukraine high-ranking
government officials colluded with
um uh the Clinton the Democrats to try
and help Hillary Clinton to hurt Donald
Trump and it wasn't like a grand
orchestrated Ukrainian government
operation it was a small thing that's
true Politico reported it I mean maybe
it's not true maybe Politico made it up
you pick but I can only operate based on
what these news outlets claim is true I
believe that was that may have been
kendallenium who reported I'm not
entirely sure but for John Harwood to
come out and say it was Kremlin
propaganda when the reporting was
literally Politico and the New York
Times reported Ukrainian court rules
that ukrainians were meddling in the U.S
election I'm like that happened
but what do you end up with they impeach
Donald Trump on fabricated narratives
now look you've got to like Trump at
this point I was like look I'm I'm stop
making me defend the guy how are we
supposed to reconcile what's happening
when you have people who are just
outright believing made up trash this
guy John Harwood literally made that up
I want to say that again John Harwood
completely fabricated this statement
disseminating information he made up in
his own mind
and he gets away with it that uh does
confirm everything I know about hardwood
by the way yeah
but so so so it's two realities you've
got the establishment desperately trying
to hold on for control and maybe they
won't they won't make it maybe they
won't be able to because of the
expansion of new technologies and
because you know our generation is just
more social media Savvy young people are
not going to be watching the TV in this
way Meet the Press is probably going to
be worthless but YouTube still props
them up puts them on the front page
so it is we live in an age of propaganda
and and the problem is that would be
difficult that would be a big problem
even if we are a highly educated society
that could you know tell but you do
polling today and you see a majority of
Americans can't tell facts from opinion
so
um this is on multiple fronts
um there are problems and
um you know like I I think you know if
if we're being honest with ourselves
there's going to be a little bit more
pain before things get better yeah I
think one of the challenges is that uh
have you ever been to Northern Ireland
no
so I went there and far be it for me to
be an expert but I saw some Illusions
that's not Illusions allusions to some
of the things we're seeing here and
that's the peace wall separating the you
know the different sides in the in the
fighting that took place in Northern
Ireland and on one side they're
pro-israel and there's a bunch of art
you know and on the other side the pro
Palestine and I'm like what does that
have to do with your conflict it didn't
matter it was tribalism if one side
adopted an idea the other side adopted
the Counterpoint and and that's what I
see here if you have entire Generations
that are raised in completely different
realities
but let's talk about some big Tech real
quick before we go get into the Super
Chat segment I got to talk about this
this is huge news we got this from
timcast.com neutral video platform
Rumble to go public with an initial
Enterprise value of 2.1 billion dollars
Rumble skyrocketing viewer engagement is
a promising sign
yeah it's true
um uh they're PR it is a promising sign
basically they're doing a spack a
special purpose acquisition company
through the Canter Finance through
Canter um I'm sorry yeah Canter
Fitzgerald that's what it's called
they say CF acquisition court cfvi is a
Global Financial Services firm led by
Cantor Financial chairman and chief
executive Howard L I'm sorry Howard W
lutnik it's a SPAC meaning it has no
commercial operations and exists only to
raise money through an initial public
offering it exists with the intention of
merging with another company so we know
that it's going to be merging with
Rumble the company will then become
Rumble effectively allowing Rumble to go
public but it also then does bring in
this other institutional investment firm
as people with power over Rumble I think
there's some really good things here
there's also some really bad things here
and the first thing I'll say is man Ian
did you call it dude get ready for State
Street BlackRock and then what's that
other investment firm the other big one
Blackstone I don't know no BlackRock
State Street and there's a third one
they're all going to put a percent into
this company get ready why would not
these big you know BlackRock and when
whatever why wouldn't they be like oh
yeah we'll buy shares yeah oh it's
publicly public trading look at Apple
Microsoft uh alphabet you see BlackRock
State Street the same investment firms
own like seven to eight percent of
almost all these top companies it's
crazy they just get a little bit so it
doesn't look like they have too much
control they got a little bit almost
everything first I'll say the good it's
great that there is competition to
YouTube it's great that Rumble is
growing these are net positives but I
don't think it's a long-term solution
if now with rumble's supposedly going to
have I think what do they say 400
million uh in proceeds Rumble will
receive approximately 400 million
dollars in proceeds a combination of a
fully committed pipe of 100 million
dollars at ten dollars per share and 300
million of cash held in the trust
account of cfvi I don't know how much
they'll be able to spend but if this
means that Rumble can then go to
prominent individuals and say how much
do you make on YouTube and they go oh I
make you know 10K a month and they say
we'll give you 11. move to rumble and
they'll go done is it that easy don't
you have to like spend all this time and
effort building the audience and all
that you do but
um I mean look one of the biggest
problems with competing with YouTube is
that Google subsidizes YouTube so
they're putting way more money in the
platform actually makes they're
effectively doing just that stay on our
platform you're going to make all this
money based on your viewer account
Rumble can counter that and they did by
basically doing deals with people will
give you X years at x amount of money to
produce content on the platform then
we'll help you know it'll help us grow
we'll help you grow put you on the front
page that can be really powerful what
Rumble needs to do right now with this
money is they need to buy Billboards and
I know it sounds silly and it's archaic
and silly you know old school but you
need that mainstream presence where
regular people are going to see Rumble
they're going to see Glenn green weld up
on a billboard and on Sunset Boulevard
or in New York and that that means
something that means Rumble is
mainstream and it's not that expensive
to do especially if they have this so
that's the good here here's the bad as
Ian pointed out all of these big
institutional investment firms are going
to get their pinkies in it very easily
it's publicly traded once they have
enough control Rumble is done people say
yeah but look Chris the CEO pavlovsky is
still going to be involved in full
disclosure I've talked to him I you know
I I digitally know him I've never met
him in person and I said yes and when I
worked at Vice Shane Smith the CEO
controlled the board and that became a
feminist company in a couple years after
they took investment from large
institutional investment firms that I
mean Vice had investment from other
places before I got there but when when
Disney came came in when Fox came in and
these people invested and then he said
don't worry I control the board it took
it took two and a half years and the
company became woke feminist and like a
CEO you're he's used uh what's his name
again Chris Chris pavlovkin Chris
probably used to call in all the shots
he walks into the meeting he says we're
doing this we're doing that and now I
know he's still a majority shareholder
so I think he still has board control
but he's going to be surrounded by
people that are harping on him every day
he's going to get tired of those
meetings and then he wants then he's
going to want to get out I'm not saying
it's going to happen but that's usually
what will happen they are using
attrition to get you out I just looked
up alphabet shareholders as of December
20. this is a company that owns Google
that owns YouTube Vanguard is their top
investment holder it's so it's State
Street Black Rock and Vanguard these
three investment firms vanguard's got
6.4 percent BlackRock is 5.5 they're
gonna get in the ground floor man it's
gonna be pennies those three companies
own about 20 of your company they if
they collude I don't know I've never
seen proof of it but it's it's not that
it's um you know what I was told by
someone who is a former executive advice
the reason they got woke was because the
investors all came in and even though
they didn't have majority power or
anything they said we have enough power
on the back end outside your company you
need to do this now and they were like
all right we'll make the changes so
first I'll break down the worst of it
Dave rubin's promises are worthless Dave
Rubin after patreon do you remember
patreon banned people that whole thing
so he goes to these creators people like
Michael malice
um you know and he says look Joe my
platform you know me you can call me
we're not going to ban you you know we
know you know what this is all about
we're going to make a safe place well
then locals sold to rumble
Dave I I don't know exactly what his
position is but he's like no nothing's
changed it's like I'm still involved
like we're not going to ban anybody but
now now anything he promised you is
meaningless because locals is owned by
Rumble so now it's Chris do you trust
Chris well I never had a deal with that
guy like so maybe maybe you're someone
on locals you're like I never talk to
like I don't know who he is how am I
supposed to get a hold of him I guess
I'll still maybe maybe maybe Reuben can
still help me out now they've done this
public SPAC deal and they've got
institutional investors involved as
advisors legal and the legal for legal
advisement and financial advisement and
as Ian pointed out why would not these
big farms be like hey a massively
expanding company that gained 8 million
users in a month I'm in right A lot of
people might want to buy into that and
then all of a sudden they're going to
say my bottom line is being threatened
because you're hosting X content or why
content or Z content and then what
happens now what happens now when the
institutional investors are involved and
all of a sudden your locals account gets
nuked
that would be really bad for their
business so I don't see it happening
anytime soon but it just it says to me
that what I really don't like is that
following the crisis of Patron of the
censorship Dave Rubin went to a ton of
people and said trust me and then it was
what two years later he sold that and
his promise is gone these people they
own their data that's what Dave says
yeah well good luck getting two to five
thousand people who have subscribed to
your platform to leave and know where
your new platform is you get locked in
you're giving a percentage of your
income to them and their promises became
worthless the moment they sold the
company now they say oh don't worry
Chris is you know he's going to retain
majority control great I've seen that
happen before it's meaningless these
companies get in they invest it doesn't
matter they've opened the door and said
anybody who wants in can get in and that
means anyone who opposes Free Speech can
simply just George Soros he could be
like all right I will buy whatever I can
buy he'll he'll buy like a stock in a
bunch of companies that'll buy stock
that's right so it'll look like 12
different companies but Soros owns six
percent of each of them Bill Gates likes
to do that too so there's uh Koch
brothers but then they get into the ESG
social corporate credit score and then
they are really put into a place where
they have to comply or they lose all of
their funding lose all of their money
and that's really where they get a lot
of big corporations so is the fear that
that Rumble is going to be YouTube in
five years
humble's going to be bought by alphabet
into that's my fear is that we're almost
gonna get bought by Microsoft it's
probably not too well they'll probably
look at an Anti-Trust lawsuits if they
do but like so why and I hope not like I
really doubt like here's the thing like
we're in a market economy there's
probably half a dozen or or more a dozen
competitors to Rumble that we haven't
even talked about yet like like there
are solutions to this issue yeah and you
you know the video space much better
than me
um you know hopefully hopefully Rumble
recognizes that they have value in
allowing different voices on their
platform and and here's my hunch like
like YouTube so far has navigated this
um you start kicking off enough people
and choking their their speech you're
going to lose you're going to lose not
just your audience but the people
producing the content
um how much are you publishing on
YouTube now so we do uh I think probably
close to three hours every day okay well
that's a lot and we and we do put a lot
we do use Rumble and we you and um and
we also post on uh bit shoot and and
odyssey and uh look like I this worries
me for the long term you know situation
with Rumble and and trying to fight
censorship the the problem is it feels
like we we we were facing a crisis of
censorship and we had people like Dave
and Chris be like everybody quick hop on
board this this the safety ship and then
it's like turning around and going right
back to Google it's going right back to
Big Tech and institutional investment
you're like we're trying to get away
from this so it's like three years of
hard work was just erased because the we
know the path this leads down and I'm
I'm gonna stress this point
everything Ian said about this happened
when when it when it came to locals when
it came to local selling when it came to
what what when it comes to what Rumble
was going to do now he's predicting the
big firms will buy up a percentage I'd
be willing to bet Ian's right about this
and I think it's fair to say considering
he co-founded mines and watched the
process of investment coming in not that
mines no and thank God we stayed private
and and Tim cast is private I think
private company is the way to go you can
take a private company to the top you do
not need to sell out no great call by
the way like like the fact that you even
saw that coming is pretty impressive we
didn't think it was going to be in three
weeks it was fast Dave basically said
hey Chris let me sell you locals I'll
take a percentage of Rumble they're cool
and then we'll go public and I mean it
was like a month that happened he sold
it and then they went publicly hey I I I
got I kind of feel like the speed at
which it was it was late October that
locals announced it was being acquired
by Rumble and then about a month later
Rumble announces back with with with
Canter Fitzgerald to to do you know uh
to go public and now they're saying it's
a 2.1 billion dollar company and I'm
like sounds like a cash out to me sounds
like creating a massive risk to the
users who are looking for people who
believed in their rights their free
speech and we're going to create a space
but you know what here's what I said
before I'll say it again good for them
for being entrepreneurs they have a
right to do what they did people like
the platform want to use it Michael
malice was like you know look I needed a
space Dave Ramen offered it to me I know
him and I feel better on here than I do
on patreon so it works for me and my
attitude is like I wish we had the
millions of dollars to fund our
operation for our decentralized Tech
while when all this was going on so that
instead of there being a rumble that
says we're going public and we're going
to allow which effectively allows
anybody to come in and buy in which
means the bad guys are now the doors
open to them if we had gone at the same
time and we had you know the
decentralized tech we had we'd be like
we don't own it we can't sell it if we
wanted to are you looking at like
blockchain stuff like to for hosting oh
that'd be awesome yeah or I I PFS stuff
like decentralized Mesh networking yeah
that's a big big part of it I've been
thinking about it all all morning like
uh decentralized hosting no that's the
way I mean that's what we need right
like I we were talking earlier somebody
in the group downstairs
um you know like if we saw it with what
was it parlor if if you don't have you
know access to they can cut you off that
fast like weren't they accessing Amazon
servers yeah parlor was on AWS Amazon
shut them down just like that yeah yep
yeah ethereum is on AWS isn't it I don't
know the erc20 network I don't know
where it rides if it's on a multitude of
ideally now you would have access to a
multitude of servers and if AWS Cuts you
off you can immediately within like 10
to 15 minutes poured over all your new
data to a new server that maybe it's in
your house or I want to make raspberry
pies and preload the software and sell
them as part of the organization Dan
bongino is an investor into Rumble I
believe Peter Thiel is too as well I've
heard that and I think Peter Thiel is
fairly opposed to a lot of the wokeness
and all that stuff I mean he didn't like
gawk or he went after them he's he's
spoken out I think
so and I I know for a fact Dave is as
well so all of these people I know you
know have been fighting against
authoritarianism and a lot of bad stuff
the problem is you go public you've
opened the door and you said come on in
the years of Bilderberg uh board member
I talked to him I had many interesting
conversations with him about that uh on
on the you know at the YouTube channel
but uh it's it's hard because a lot of
people put their full faith and trust
into a lot of these platforms and a lot
of times they don't know what's going to
happen with that huge business with that
huge infrastructure and that's why I I
don't put any fate
um in anything you never else I could
trust him you never I have my own
private business my own platform and I'm
building that up and have been building
that up for over 10 years you should
never have to trust a person in a
corporation the contract should speak
for itself what the companies and then
but the thing is people trust Elon Musk
they want to like him they have hope for
the future because superheroes do exist
so I was just gonna say for for years
now I think I've joked that you know
Peter thielen must need to get together
and open launch their own social network
that's going to be a platform people can
actually speak on without fear of
getting just mixed like that I if it's
decentralized yeah but then like is it
even a platform anymore that's a good
conversation to have let's go to super
chats if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends it
really helps and go to timcast.com
become a member we have a members only
segment coming up around 11 or so PM but
let's see what you guys got to say
we got this from
a sense of muse three says Tim I sent a
package to you that was returned
unclaimed so I sent it again hopefully
the post office places a notice in your
P.O box this time hope you get the
package uh the problem was we got too
much stuff sent to us there was so much
stuff they started just kicking back the
stuff that was coming and that's a
bummer I'm like uh what are we supposed
to do we told the post office like hey
we get stuff sent here and they're like
yeah well too much stuff got sent here
and I'm like
okay I guess yeah yeah I don't know so
but uh it should be a problem we like we
worked it out and we think we have like
more space and we're gonna increase the
frequency of pickups and things like
that so feel free to send away if you'd
like to uh send stuff to us
Julie B says check out Global difference
group they're helping people protect
themselves from the vax passports
interesting not heard of that what were
they called Global difference group huh
it was interesting Trinity says look at
strong concordance then read Revelations
18 23 sorceries mean pharmacia pharmacia
okay so that's Strong's Concordance
Strong's Concordance yeah what is that
yeah so a concordance is like a way to
reference Bible verses and like kind of
correlate them with other Bible verses
get translations for words and stuff
it's really interesting what she has to
say about
um
all right Neanderthal says it's even
worse than you know Tim the vax pass
will expire every six months in Germany
and your vaccination status expires
every night yeah yep and the European
commissioner president just said that
she wants to start a discussion about
making it mandatory for all of Europe
this after a month when she was seen
canoodling with the Pfizer CEO oh that's
right yeah
man jeez
Chad L says do the people that drive
alone with the mask also lay alone in
bed with a condom on
some great comment I hope they wake up
with it on too I'm making a shirt
that's going to be a shirt
taking a note
Nate says correct me if I'm wrong but
isn't a virus's goal to survive and not
kill the host yes you are correct so
well I don't know if that's a goal but
what point of its existence
reproduction so wouldn't it be the
virus's best interest to become more
transmissible and less deadly yeah that
might be a high uh a high thought oh
well love the show um you're correct
that's that's literally true yeah what's
been happening with covet is that the
initial strain
was really brutal really really brutal
but because it was so brutal people were
quarantining we had shut things down and
then what ends up happening is the more
brutal version struggles to spread
because people are too sick so then what
happens is when variants start emerging
the there's probably deadlier variants
they don't go anywhere super deadly
doesn't go anywhere but the transmission
transmissible one that's less deadly
gets somebody mildly sick now they're
like I'm fine I can go to work they get
other people sick the less deadly one
spreads more and more and more over the
past two years we have seen you know the
the strains become less deadly but more
transmissible which makes total sense
you might end up with the sniffles and
ignore it and then all of a sudden
you're spreading you know the the
whatever variant the fouchy ver the
stelter variant ideally you have no
symptoms I think someone was saying
metamine mutant that there are like
thousands of viruses and bacterium in
the human body just I don't know I don't
have the exact numbers but we've learned
to live with them we've overcome the the
negative side effects so from my
understand my
own body is
low price of bacteria and a lot of a lot
of different viruses that make us have
symptoms that we don't even recognize
and they've become so subtle they spread
that way we never even know we have them
I'm hopeful and some bacteria is good
like your gut bacteria I bet some
viruses are good I have no evidence for
that but they probably have helped us
evolve over the decade possible
definitely yeah all right the vagrancy
horror says hey Tim could you could my
Eldritch Horror Story Channel get a
shout out P.S Luke I think you'd like it
a lot cool very cool we got two super
chats here from Brett tesdel and H Music
referencing that Rand Paul was on
crowded this morning and suggested that
pharmaceutical companies have a Delta
specific vaccine interesting oh Rand
said that uh Ricky Ford's the same thing
Rand Paul told Crowder this morning that
they have a Delta variant vaccine
interesting I didn't know that well
Congress and you know the special
superclass usually has a whole different
set of medications and protocols than
the plebs do that's right I think
that'll ever change are we gonna have a
vaccine now for every variant is that
the idea and then you got to get all of
them collect them I don't know Full
Slate Ace Prater says I demanded HR have
legal send me a statement they will or
will not require vaccines for continued
medical benefits for employees and
children for coverage they sat on the
fence like Luke last night what was Luke
I said I was sitting on the fence but
then I pretty much exposed my after the
show Luke was just like pro-life all the
way you know no no we had a we had a
very uh we had a very interesting
conversation that didn't include or not
that created that created the thought of
creating children rather than settling
please no Blister in MCE says as an
Australian I am disgusted at the
cognitive dissonance of the rest of my
country a county county or country
um well pinned to the chat right now is
our poster trolling the entire country
of Australia and you can pick that up
there's also a t-shirt so if you go to
timcast.com and click store you will see
the T-shirt version in the poster
version we're gonna get one of the
posters and hang them up it's gonna be a
lot of fun it's a vacation it's like
come visit Howard Springs there's razor
wire staycation people running from guys
come to stay people people did start
saying you can check out anytime but you
can never leave it oh snap yeah somebody
said beach towel incoming
all right let's see
Jimmy Freckle says keep up the good work
this is our moment remember us all right
appreciate me thank you sir
unreasonably angry says Jesse going for
eggs at two in the morning reminds me of
that one scene from SpongeBob where
Patrick wakes up and goes oh boy 3 A.M
and pulls out a random Krabby Patty
did you guys know that was the story
with Jesse Smith no he was going for
eggs Subways no no eggs wow
he said that he had a craving for eggs
at two in the morning but Walgreens was
closed so he went to Subway that's a
horrible excuse me
who can't relate with a man who can't
relate with someone who woke up at 2AM
with the neck cream how long is that
trial gonna go on oh it's going to be
done quick okay yeah yeah they've I
guess both brothers have already
testified and I love it the New York
Post reported that they testified they
would have sleepovers together and I'm
like I I don't think that's what adults
call it yeah but sure
there's a
family-friendly showing them again
yeah but they were getting drugs for him
and both brothers I think were basically
like yeah they paid us to do it you know
there's bath houses involved but I think
it's fair to point out these two guys
if like we don't have to trust them you
know what I mean if they're claiming
they were in on it for all we know they
went to Jesse and they were like hey we
got an idea we'll make a ton of we'll
make a ton of money you win and Jesse
was like all right I'm in you know what
I mean like doesn't matter well well I'm
just saying like we shouldn't act like
these two guys we're just like Jesse's
asked us to do it he's our friend they
they're willing co-conspirators like
they should be charged too for this yeah
do they have immunity I think they
probably probably uh to testify because
Jesse's the big fish they got a deal of
some kind yeah
Ted scannon says Ian yes increasing the
number of Representatives would increase
the bribe sorry lobbying money
corporations would have to spend and
there would be better representation
based upon population more maybe but
then we'll have to increase it again in
the future I like the idea of removing
the House of Representatives and just
having it be like a smart contract that
triggers when the votes come in of your
jurisdiction and says yes or no for you
don't have to rely on a human to do it
for you that way the the program can't
get bribed could get hacked but it
couldn't get deprived BlackRock beacon
says I agree that the culture war is a
fifth generational conflict but the goal
of fifth generational tactics is to
weaken and disorganize the target so
they are either unable to mount an
effective defense or Force to surrender
however all fights end on the ground
man interesting when I was a kid almost
every fight that would break out would
be a wrestling match yeah and I was like
when I watch movies they do like kicks
and blocks and stuff how come you guys
just like roll around on the ground like
shoving each other you know what I mean
I was a wrestler that was my sport oh
that's a good one I guess because it
comes in handy yeah you can put some
into submission you win you know what I
mean
Colin Sanders says peaceful divorce
because corrupt politicians Drunk on
Power are well known for letting the
peasants take the ball and go home
totally how it goes oh yeah
Billy Bob says I would love to hear your
views on the idea of Corporations
getting involved in a civil war turning
it into the first corporate Wars like
cyberpunk it's actually a really
interesting idea I think you were saying
that ready yeah that's terrifying it's a
Stephen King novel well maybe not a
Stephen King but like a good Sci-Fi all
these unemployed people now that are out
of work and then if if inflation like
Luke was saying if it gets really really
really bad which it looks like it's on
track the corporations have enough money
to pay people to join them to do
whatever they get paid to do which is
like be part of our armed militia we
need more land to produce more drones
and then the government's going to be
completely as they are impotent I mean
they'll be commanding the military
but then the military will be getting
bribed by the corporations yeah
and like darp like these corporations
already are selling arms to US
Government why wouldn't they just stop
and start selling their weapons to to
Amazon instead
we could write a novel that does sound
like like a Running Man story there in
the making we should make some short
films man yeah is anybody out there a
good film producer with like cool
effects we'll build a green screen room
and then we can do crazy you know we can
like I don't know I watched Cowboy Bebop
the Remake and it's basically just all
green screen room stuff and I'm like it
looks really cool but what's wrong with
their writers yeah you know I guess
they're remaking uu Haku show now or
something because they're like you know
kids watched Adults Swim and now they're
older and they're gonna want to watch
our new Nostalgia it seemed like they
were trying to make it a cartoon did you
guys see Cowboy Bebop it looked like
they were trying to make a cartoon a
real show which didn't translate like I
saw the Ed thing and her being all like
an anime character she kind of did it
right but it didn't translate yeah it
was someone commented the Cowboy Bebop
Ed scene was like being at Comic-Con and
seeing some dumb kid doing a cosplay in
the middle of the hallway and I'm like
that sounds about right yeah but I don't
think the show was bad you know I liked
it and I think uh Mustafa who played
black nailed it
um his voice man he got the voice
perfect I was impressed and I like the
show it's not the same show at all the
problem is they tried to make a
live-action show like a cartoon and I'm
like what are you doing make it a
live-action show it's got to be
different
but that's uh there you go let's make
some short films make some sci-fi I do a
lot of cool stuff on green screens now
talk to Sean Malone he's he's video guys
he's great well we'll do we'll make an
entire room that's green the whole room
with panels you get like and you stack
panels modularly all over like around
you and kind of I don't know if you
stand on green or not you can you know
and we'll do vaulted vaulted ceiling I
don't know if that'll work but we'll do
good lights and everything and then
we'll put Ian in outer space oh finally
he's already there
or but you guys want to go with me
hey have you guys seen uh Silicon Valley
a little bit I think their whole joke
was against Bezos like the the guy runs
a spoof company Huli he's like the
villain in uh their logo is it's well
it's it's genitalia and I'm like they're
making a joke at Bezos Somebody went to
Bezos and said here's our proposal for
the design and he went that looks like a
dick and they were like it does he goes
run with it
because he did he had to approve it of
course wouldn't it be funny if like he
didn't and he had like some like
lieutenants and he was like guys get it
done do it make sense he said you got it
and then these guys were just like not
paying attention when they were doing
the plans and then finally Bezos looks
at it and he's like it's complete and
they're like there it is he's like it's
a giant dick it sure is
there's a lot of salads exceeding the
universe all right oh man
they're like the ejection Port is right
up at the top it's right at the tip so
that's where that's where you come out
of the and the shuttle I mean Amazon is
going to screw you literally especially
with the Washington Post and CIA and
their encryption breaking technology and
facial recognition technology that
Amazon is also building so it's only a
matter of time until you get that rocket
Mike Peterson says screw Luke no Ian I'm
leaving they'll screw you too buddy
everyone's gonna be walking out because
everyone else is puking
no Luke we nuke sounds better than we
puke because puke has a u sound in it
you know I don't care all right medley
Butler III says if fascism is the merger
of big business and government then it
truly began in 1910 on Jekyll Island and
110 years later the world still has no
idea good point yeah when you were
talking about the first kind of the
introduction of fascism being in the
modern era I was thinking of Woodrow
Wilson a lot of people say he was like
the most fascist American president of
vice president U.S history and I didn't
even think of the Federal Reserve while
you were talking earlier but that
definitely it seems like some they got
their their talents in right I mean if
you look if you read you know if you
read Marx one of the things he he says
get control of a banking centralizing of
money and it's one of the many things
that we unfortunately listen to Marx on
all right
Socratic disciple says here's an idea
Tim if you want people to realize that
you're not making it up post your
sources as links in the video
descriptions that would be very helpful
to the rest of us who want to share your
arguments with our friends and family
there was an issue with when you put
links and descriptions what how YouTube
negatively impacts the content and
that's why what I do is I include the
URL in every single video at the top you
can see it and you can see the news
guard certification and that's why the
screen on my main show is always mostly
the news article so you can literally
see it and it's very easy if you see the
title of the article type it in and
you'll find the source it's not that
difficult I'm not saying that to be
difficult or condescending uh one of the
issues I guess was that I was I was told
uh and I've experienced this if you
start loading up links YouTube's view of
that is the more you link off the
platform that that you're taking away
from them so I was like okay well I'll
include it visually in everything you
can see the article you can see it you
can see the certification the issue I'm
referring to is that people who are just
listening to Joe Rogan and none of these
sources are there are just like he must
be making all of this up it's like well
if you only watch CNN you'd probably
think that
we got sources for all our stuff
all right Austin Scott says Psalm 37 13
also I sent you guys a gift to your PO
Box did you get it we may have we have
new shelves for all the mail we're
getting because we're getting slammed by
tons of mail is crazy you guys are
awesome thanks so much for sending us
all this stuff lots of cool stuff I
really appreciate it I uh debuted
officer Jack boot Jackson on one of the
Vlogs opening some of your packages and
uh it's always cool when you know you
pick up people who are whoever you like
in the house when you send them stuff
it's really awesome and a very cool
personalized experience that I love
Kevin Pilgrim says did you see Ennis
Cantor as legally changing his name to
freedom and his Canter yeah I did see
that that's awesome so freedom is on his
jersey good for him yep yep I tried to
buy that Jersey uh they don't have it up
yet
free really now says screw Dave and
Rumble sellouts look I'm wondering what
you guys think about that because
obviously I ranted like do you think
it's selling out what they did
what they're doing you kind of got to
Define sell out but like is it is it
that they're trying to make money for
themselves or do you think they're
trying to grow the business to to fight
for a night like for the freedom of
speech part of it that strikes me as a
sellout is when Dave said I'm gonna make
sure you never get banned and then he
sold their that
um that responsibility away that was the
big sellout to me not necessarily the
worst part of it by any means you could
say do whatever you want in business uh
but that that is yeah I mean I feel like
he led people astray it was very weird
coming from him it very much felt to me
like he saw that people were worried
about getting censored censored and it
was an opportunity to basically get all
of these deals and then as soon as he
had this Pantheon he sold it don't know
Reuben I will say it sounds a little
exploitative right like like he saw an
opportunity and maybe he was excited
about the opportunity and it could work
to his benefit and and he wasn't looking
much beyond that I mean to be fair
that's just Enterprise you know he saw
he saw a hole in the market he took
advantage of the hole in the market he
provided a service that people agreed to
sign up for and wanted and then he got
his exit you know I'm not saying he took
a bunch of money out of it I don't think
he got paid a whole lot for the
acquisition but it is interesting that a
month after the acquisition they do a
SPAC deal and I had I have to believe
that Dave knew about all that because I
I can't imagine you know how long does
it take to do to do a spec deal like
this how much how many legal forms I
wouldn't be surprised if the investment
firm you know was talking with Rumble
and they're like guys you just don't
have it you're missing a core component
you're missing what brings people in and
you're missing a core element of uh
monetization
you're missing the names they were
missing Michael malice and was Blair on
there yes they needed the names that's
why Spotify got Rogan that's why mines
wanted you that's why uh uh Rumble hired
a bunch of people they got uh siraj they
got Glenn Greenwald they they basically
they contracted them to produce content
so I think you're right I also think
though they're looking at monetization
in the sense where it's like what's how
do you how do you make money off this
and so they go to Dave and they're like
look we wanted this is just my opinion
if I was to speculate we want to do a
spec deal these contracts probably took
months to prepare there's no way they
pulled it off in just a month I mean
I've been working on contracts for
people just to get a show produced takes
two months to go through you know work
out the deal so I can't imagine that
they they didn't know this was happening
which says to me the likelihood is they
knew they were working the deal they
needed a component of people subscribing
and paying money to the creators they
like something they could add to the mix
they are still separate websites then
they go to Dave and say Here's what's
going to happen Dave must have known
about it I see their two point or the
2.1 billion valuation I think I want to
see what it was before they acquired wow
they were private yeah yeah how much
would they been worth then I think your
instincts sound about right like as far
like this this deal has probably been in
the in the works for months
um and and whether he knew or maybe they
just said hey look we need people
um maybe he knew about the deal maybe he
didn't
um it might not have maybe I'll tell you
I don't know how I know I'd ask next
time I see him yeah it's possible you
know the famous story with Bill Gates is
that IBM needed an operating system so
he said I got one and I'll give it to
you and I'm I'm probably getting the
story wrong but the general idea was he
was like yeah we definitely have an
operating system for you that's great we
want a dollar per machine and they're
like great he walks out of the meeting
and he's like okay now we need an
operating system he eventually finds a
guy who created the uh you know the Dosa
dos which is you know operating system
and then buys it offer for 50 Grand then
goes to IBM and says here it is and so I
mean yeah I'm thinking anything wrong it
was his deal he had it this other guy
didn't and he gave the guy 50 grand for
the operating system he put together and
then he went and sold it and made a lot
more money off it from the from the deal
so Dave may have had no idea they may
have come to him and say we want to
acquire uh Rumble it'll be great we're
gonna have this video infrastructure to
help you guys out lower your cost it'll
be better for everyone Dave probably
like sound good to me and then Dave may
find may have found out about this the
moment it happened considering he's
deeply involved in or claims he's still
involved I really doubt it oh yeah
because they paid him in stock you don't
accidentally take stock first you know
that for sure that's what he said on his
announcement video Dave did he said I
received stock yeah Dave knew the whole
time that's why I took the stock because
they were about to go public no yep
that's right oh wow and I don't know
that and they're gonna they're gonna get
a bonus depending on if the stock value
reaches a certain number fifteen dollars
if it reaches 15 bucks they get a bit
they get more shares right and if you
look at what IPOs are doing like these
spec IPOs are all exploding yeah maybe
they're going to slow down but yeah like
they're doing very well and then about
three days later they they taper off yo
it is possible that Rumble becomes the
next most amazing thing frees their
software code federates with minds and
be and really does upend big Tech that
is possible I'm waiting for it yeah
let's go
so what is what does that mean real
quick because I I want to read some
someone mentioned that they they a
financial advisor I don't want to read
this but I just want what what do you
think it means morally and ethically if
Rumble had been working on the steel for
some time
went to Dave and said we're about to do
a SPAC deal we're going to go public
we want to acquire you know locals we'll
give you stock in exchange for this you
know what really really pisses me off
about that if that's the case
is that Dave the value he brought here
is literally just he convinced all of
these people to sign up for a platform
that is in my opinion
it took us I think three days to make
ours for for to be fair for just one you
know site that auto it auto populated
content we could post articles we could
post blogs and all that stuff it's very
easy to do this WordPress stuff granted
they probably did a little bit more work
have their own proprietary code and all
that stuff but the real selling point to
give Dave the stock was not the system
they built it was the people he signed
up for it and I wonder how much stock he
got if he knew when he was approached by
Rumble we're going public I just feel
like that was
the definition of exploiting a crisis
and manipulating people to you know you
know what I gotta say look if you're a
capitalist you're an Enterprise guy
you're probably fine with it that's fine
by me whatever if you're David who talks
about big Tech is a problem it is that's
different man I'm I'm fully with you
that be a be a capitalist and and make
your money and and screw along the way
if you need to to get there but ethics
man and if you're gonna talk about
something don't go and do the opposite
that's crazy yeah no ethically I'm with
you like like people I know I I kind of
in look maybe he convinced himself and
this is all speculation because I know
less about the deal than you guys do
like as you said I didn't even know he
had he got stuck for it
um but people I know if I'm doing if I'm
gonna try to convince them for my
selfish motives there's something kind
of in Conflict there
yeah I I believe in like the good
wholesome capitalism where someone
invents a light bulb and it lights up
the world for everybody that person
becomes rich because they made the world
genuinely a better place well you get
people like Thomas Edison and they're
like that filament's lasting too long
how are we supposed to sell these things
can somebody make a crappier filament
that burns out so we can consistently
sell these things what a dick planned
obsolescence that's right actually a a
exactly a term that's thrown around
because it's so common really now says
I'm a financial advisor this stuff
doesn't happen overnight I love him and
have been an avid watcher of Dave's show
yeah I love Dave I think he's done a lot
of good and I think he's been I think he
really didn't realize his his role in
big Tech in doing this I I think he
didn't realize that he was by making
proprietary social networking and
selling to other that he was it's not
personal what bothers me is we are
fighting tooth and nail every day
Against The Establishment the censorship
machine and what we need is resilience
and the best thing I could have said was
like I understand that what Davis
created is a centralized you know system
and there's a risk of being shut down
but at the very least at least it's
private can't say that anymore now
anyone can buy in I mean like you said
Vanguard uh
he literally sold out literally so like
like let's call it spade a spade here
the good thing is how invested are you
at this point I was thinking about
buying Rumble stock I don't know if it's
gonna play like one of these meme stocks
now people people said Tim buy as much
as you can then and I'm like no I don't
support it I mean I don't hate anyone
involved with it I just don't support
big deals so I haven't invested yet we
literally use Rumble infrastructure as
as a business client I guess I'm on
YouTube right now
they're great they offer a great service
it's it's a way better price point than
anyone else I we use them they're good
my issue is just like don't come to me
and claim you're fighting for free
speech yeah this is what's happening you
know
all right let's just read one more here
Hunter caught says you talk about
planned obsolescence as if these
vaccines don't have planned obsolescence
yeah I don't that's that's very very
different but I certainly think we're
heading towards a subscription plan and
the joke I made was use promo code fauci
auchi to get ten dollars off you know
blah blah blah all right here's another
one home B says problem with the light
bulb light pollution big cities lost
touch to the universe when they lost the
Stars that's a great point I agree did
you guys know that in the I believe it
was in the 90s the local police stations
in in Los Angeles started getting
inundated with phone calls about
something strange in the sky
and what people were seeing was the
Milky Way
power had gone out and for the first
time people saw the Milky Way in the sky
and were confused by it that's a cool
animal it's beautiful though I mean I
think we went I think you were there uh
with me we went to the desert in Las
Vegas during uh Defcon and like when you
see the stars up for what they truly are
without any light pollution it is
I was gonna say austunning again uh a
word you made up uh yeah I'm gonna use
it again it's all stunning and beautiful
and and definitely gives you a
perspective on your existence that
really does humble you comparatively to
all the other superficial bull crap
around it kind of underlines what you
were saying earlier about it if if
social media gets more entrenched in
people that we might see a civil war
it's not the Civil War and but then and
more self-destruct and it kept making me
think get away from the computer go into
the woods experience nature because
maybe that is the solution to World
Peace no humans need it especially right
now like I remember like the first time
I saw the Milky Way in the Badlands with
no light for miles and miles and it was
like you could it was Heaven you could
reach out and all of us are addicted to
our phones right like I mean we're on it
I know I know at least you two uh are on
Twitter as much as me and it's it's
toxic but I'm on a computer when I'm
tweeting but uh the first time you saw
the Milky Way is kind of a crazy thing
to say yeah no it was I remember it back
in the day people would be like I
remember the first time I saw it I was a
baby you know but today all right anyway
my friends go to timcast.com become
members we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up at around 11 pm is
when we publish it so definitely check
that out don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel you can
follow the show just search for Tim cast
iron everywhere else we put up Clips on
Instagram so check that out hit those
like buttons and you can follow me
personally at timcast on Twitter and
Instagram you want to shout anything out
well uh yeah go visit us on feed.org is
where we publish all our content if you
want to find me John Milton Twitter
miltonmore79 also on Facebook and if I
get a few more on Facebook I'll hit my
my ten thousand numbers so let's make
that happen
I also want to shout out the the
commenter who said that the shirt I'm
wearing is going to tick some people off
I really appreciate that you can get
yours on the best political shots.com
but
um I also made a very helpful video on
Luke uncensored.com which now also
includes change media University and the
apocalypse survival course for free if
you're a part of that lucronsensor.com
hope to see some of you guys there
thanks for having me oh thanks for
coming Luke love to have you here man
hey guys great to see you again great to
be here love you John thanks for coming
hey thank you guys very much for having
me on I loved it most epic yeah I am
gonna go check out Luke's apocalypse
training now that sounds awesome you
guys may follow me on Twitter at Sarah
patchlands before we go don't forget go
to timcast.com click store and get this
visit Howard Springs poster it shows two
beautiful people sitting on the beach
surrounded by razor wire as a police
boat chasing after a man trying to
escape and it says visit Howard Springs
totally voluntary relocation Camp
Australia he's wearing a mask I love it
I'm gonna get these I'm gonna hang them
up it's gonna be beautiful they're the
best Flyers the best advertisement for
what's happening in Howard Springs memes
people will see this and they'll say
what is that and you will answer and you
will tell them and they will be confused
but they're funny I gotta question more
of these about this one is the sun
rising or setting in this picture
is right you think it's rising early
morning yeah yeah it's morning I I
thought it's Sunset earlier that means
about we also have a t-shirt version but
but you can get these posters and you
can hang them up they can you can take
the poster and you can put it you know
on your walls and people will then see
it you too can act as if you are in
Australia
put it in your window you got a
storefront put in your storefront
windows make it you know anyway thanks
for supporting us we'll see you all over
at timcast.com bye guys